COMMITTEE ON HEALTH HEARING
TODAY OUR FIRST HEARING IN THIS
ROOM- AND SO- I THINK WE CAN
MAKE EVERYTHING WORK AND WE
DON'T YOU KNOW I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE SO. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN UP HERE. BUT
IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF SPACE UP
HERE YOU GUYS LOOK REALLY FAR
AWAY TO. ANYWAY SO ANYWAY LET'S
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED BUT
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A STATEMENT ON PROVIDING
TESTIMONY AT THIS HEARING. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND WE
CAN'T SO THAT WE CAN BE
EFFECTIVE HAVE AFFECTED TO
LIBERATION AND DECISIONS ON THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA'S. AS WE PROCEED WITH
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING. THE APPLY THESE
RULES TO ALL PEOPLE. WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
ALL MAY WE ALL MAIN WITNESSES
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN PERSON.
WITHOUT TWO MAIN WITNESSES FOR
THREE MINUTES EACH. THIS'LL
TESTIMONY CAN BE MADE IN PERSON
OR OVER THE PHONE. AFTER THE
MAIN WITNESSES- WILL- WILL BE
COMBINED. AND NOT GREW BY
POSITION ON THE BILL. ALL PUBLIC
COMMENT NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE
BILL AT HAND. AMAZON OTHER
ISSUES WILL BE RULED OUT OF
ORDER IN YOUR TIME WILL RESPOND
WILL WILL EXPIRE IMMEDIATELY. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION AND
WE HOPE AUTHORS A STAKEHOLDERS
ARE RESPECTFUL OF THE PROCESS-
DUE TO CODE THE CODE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE LIMITED SPACE FOR PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET A
SOCIAL DISTANCE. OR LESS OF THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING TO
RETURN YOUR SEAT IS SPACE IF
SPACE IN THE ROOM- PERMITS. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
JUST THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
PROCESS. THE OR THE CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS
PROCEEDINGS WILL NOT ACCEPT
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR
THAT INCITES OR THREATENS
VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED THREATS.
THE RULES FOR TODAY'S HEARING
INCLUDED- TALKING ARE LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE OF THE
COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED ONLY AT
THE DESIGNATED TIME AND PLACE AS
PERMITTED BY THE CHAIR. OF A
COMMENT MUST RELATE TO THE
SUBJECT BILL OR BILLS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY. AND KNOWING
GAUGING IN CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING.
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAYES A SUBJECT
YOU TO REMOVAL RATHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESSES. WE WILL
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
AFTER THE MAIN WITNESS
TESTIMONY. CALLING FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE EIGHT FIVE
ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO. YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN THE
DAILY FILE AND ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RECALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO WELL BEFORE
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE.
PLACED WITHIN THE QUEUE. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE MUTE YOUR LIVE
STREAM AND SO YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION. YOUR
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED UPON BY THE
MODERATOR SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING A PER ANY PROBLEM WITH
THE MODERATED TELL. TELEPHONE
SERVICE. ALCOHOLIC ARE COMMITTEE
AT. 916-319-2097 AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP. WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL WITH INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN
FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE
THERE AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
STILL FACE. BILLS WILL BE HEARD
IN ORDER AND THE ORDER PRINTED
IN THE DAILY FILE. AND ON OUR
AGENDA PROVIDED AT THIS HEARING
AND POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. OF THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY-
AND ANY MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
MAY REMOVE A BILL FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KERR
AGUIAR-CURRY. ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REBEKAH BARRICADE HAND-
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE SO CALLED
AROUND. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA DAVIES AND
ITEM NUMBER. ELEVEN AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM PATTERSON.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD
WE- SEE WE ARE SHORT OF A QUORUM
BUT NOT MUCH. WHICH IS GOOD.
START HERE IN THE SPRING SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH OUR- FIRST
ITEM IN WHICH WILL BE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. EIGHTEEN OH
NINE BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
BUT SIR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
RIGHT THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITMENT AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. IS THE
SAD REALITY THE SOME NURSING
HOMES IN THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA. RETREAT
RETURN. I CAN SPEAK RIGHT NOW-
RICKETT GIVE PSYCH I ENTICE
ICONIC DRUGS TO RESIDENTS WITH
DEMENTIA TO CONTROL THE BEHAVIOR
DESPITE RULES AGAINST THE MISUSE
OF SUCH DRUGS AS CHEMICAL
RESTRAINTS. THESE CHEMICAL
RESTRAINTS ARE BEING PRESCRIBED
TO SEDATE AND SUBDUE RESIDENTS
WHO OFTEN USE BEHAVIOR TO
COMMUNICATE THEIR PAIN
DISCOMFORT OR DISTRESS. AB
EIGHTEEN OH NINE WILL HELP STEM
THIS PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO A TWO HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT BY THE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH THIS ABUSIVE
PRACTICES BECOME MORE RIGHTS
WIDE SPREAD BASED ON THE
RESEARCHERS VISITS TO MORE THAN
A HUNDRED NURSING FACILITIES IN
SIX STATES AND MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED INTERVIEWS WITH PEOPLE
LIVING FACILITIES THEIR FAMILIES
STAFF LONG TERM CARE AND
DISABILITY EXPERTS. GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND ADVOCATES ARE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH REPORT THEY
WANT DOCILE OIL HOW AND HOW
NURSING HOMES IN THE UNITED
STATES OVER MEDIA PEOPLE WITH
DEMENTIA ESTIMATES THAT EVERY
WEEK AND US NURSING FACILITIES
MORE THAN A HUNDRED SOME NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE MOSTLY THOSE
OLDER LIVING WITH DEMENTIA ARE
GIVEN ANTI PSYCHOTIC DRUGS
WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATE
DIAGNOSIS. FACILITIES ADMINISTER
THESE DRUGS IN MANY CASES
WITHOUT OBTAINING INFORMED
CONSENT FROM RESIDENTS OR THEIR
FAMILIES. ANTIPSYCHOTIC DRUGS
WERE DEVELOPED TO TREAT
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS LIKE
SCHIZOPHRENIA THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO LABEL THEM WITH
THE STRONGEST BLACK BOX WARNING
ABOUT THE RISKS THEY POSE TO
PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA. THE FDA
HAS NEVER APPROVED ANTI
PSYCHOTIC DRUGS A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE FOR TREATMENT OF
DEMENTIA SYMPTOMS STUDIES FIND
THAT ANTI PSYCHOTIC DRUGS NEARLY
DOUBLE THE RISK OF DEATH IN
OLDER PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA. WHEN
THE DRUGS ARE ADMINISTERED
WITHOUT INFORMED CONSENT
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
NOT MAKING THE CHOICES TO TAKE
SUCH A RISK. AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
BUILDS ON EXISTING PROTECTIONS
FOR NURSING HOME RESIDENTS IN
STATE LAW REGULAR AND
REGULATIONS THAT CODIFIES AND
EXPANDS RULES TO ESTABLISH A
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS RIGHT TO
PROVIDE OR WITHHOLD. WRITTEN
INFORMED CONSENT PERTAINING TO
THE USE OF ANTI THERAPEUTIC
DRUGS AND THE RIGHT TO BE FREE
FROM CHEMICAL RESTRAINT. IT
SPECIFIES THAT RESIDENTS IN THE
REPRESENTATIVES MUST BE INFORMED
IN WRITING ABOUT THE CUT CONTENT
OF BLACK BOX WARNINGS FOR
PROPOSED DRUGS AND WHETHER THE
DRUGS PROPOSED USE HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE FDA. REQUIRES
THAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO EVALUATE
NURSING FACILITY COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE PROVISIONS DURING PERIODIC
STATE LICENSING INSPECTIONS. I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY TWO WITNESSES
THIS AFTERNOON AFTER THE CHECK A
TELL STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE
BILL'S SPONSOR AND CALIFORNIANS
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM. AND
LYDIA RUGEJE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE RIVAL. THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY.
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED FOR A BI EIGHTEEN OH
NINE MY NAME'S TONY TICKET TELL
I'M SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM OR SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. I WAS HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WHEN WE TRIED A BILL THAT
WAS VERY SIMILAR TO THIS ONE. IT
RECEIVED A FAIR AMOUNT OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WE GOT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT HE
ULTIMATELY VETOED IT. IS VETO
MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR SAID
ESSENTIALLY. I AM NOT CONVINCED
THAT THERE'S A REAL PROBLEM WITH
THE STRUGGLING STUFF. LET ME- AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO LOOK INTO IT AND THEN REPORT
BACK TO ME. TO SOME EXTENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH DID
THAT THEY DID IT WHAT WAS CALLED
AN ANTI PSYCHOTIC DRUG COLLECT
DRUG COLLABORATIVE. WHEN THEY
WENT INTO. ABOUT FORTY TWO
NURSING HOMES AND TOOK A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE- PSYCHOTROPIC DRUG
USAGE IN THOSE NURSING HOMES AND
THEY FOUND. A LOT OF VIOLATIONS.
BUT THAT REPORT WAS KIND OF LOST
IN AN EXPLOSION OF INTEREST IN
THIS TOPIC THAT HAPPENED AROUND
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN. SOME
MEDIA REPORTS AND SOME
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS. AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
ABOUT MISUSE OF PSYCHOTROPIC
DRUGS IN NURSING HOMES
PARTICULARLY ANTI PSYCHOTICS. N.
AS MUCH AS WE PROBABLY NEEDED IT
WE DIDN'T REALLY GET A LOT OF
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT ON THAT ON
THAT- CALL ON THE- CAMPAIGN TO
REDUCE THE USE OF ANTI PSYCHOTIC
DRUGS WHAT WE GOT WAS OF AN
EFFORT TO GET VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE WITH THE RULES- IT
WAS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT USING
PROVIDERS AND ADVOCATES AND
REGULATORS WORKING TOGETHER TO
BRING DRUG USAGE DOWN AND TO
SOME EXTENT THERE WERE SOME
SUCCESS THERE FOR. ABOUT FIVE
YEARS THE DRUG RATES CAME DOWN
NOT DRAMATICALLY BUT STEADILY
AND THERE WAS I THINK IMPROVE
DEMENTIA CARE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY I WAS I THINK IT WAS
SOME- SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK PUT INTO
THAT. BUT THE EVER KIND OF
EXHAUSTED ITSELF IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN ATTENTION
STARTED BE FOCUSED ELSEWHERE-
AND THEN SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED WE'VE HAD A TON OF
BACKSLIDING. ON THE ON THE RATES
AND IT LOOKS PRETTY MUCH LIKE IT
DID. TWELVE YEARS AGO WHEN WE
STARTED THIS STUFF. WE REALLY AT
THIS POINT WE REALLY NEED SOME
HELP FROM OUR LEGISLATORS TO GO
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE TO GET. THE BRING
INFORMED CONSENT BACK TO THE- TO
THE- FOR FRONT. OF EVERYBODY'S
MINDS WHEN IT COMES TO USING
THESE DRUGS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE VERY BEST PEOPLE TO PREVENT
MISUSE. ARE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
DO THAT AND THAT'S THE RESIDENTS
OR THE OR THEIR LOVED ONES
THEMSELVES. BOB THE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IT'S OUR NEXT
WITNESS. I'M FIRST THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SHARE MY FAMILY
STORY. I IN HER LATE EIGHTIES
MOM NEEDS TO PASS OUR ABILITY TO
CARE FOR HER. AFTER MUCH
RESEARCH WE MADE THE DRAMATIC
MOVE. ENTRUSTED HER TO STRANGERS
WITH OUR EXPERTS AND DEMENTIA
CARE. WITHIN DAYS WE GOT A PHONE
CALL FROM THE OWNER INFORMING US
THAT MAMA WAS EXHIBITING.
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR. LONG STORY
SHORT IF HER BEHAVIOR WHEN WE'RE
NOT CURB SHE'D HAVE TO LEAVE.
THE SHOCK THAT MAMA WAS A DANGER
TO ANYBODY QUICKLY TURNED TO
PANIC AT REALITY THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER PLACE FOR
HER AND NOW WITH AN AGGRESSIVE
LABEL. HOWEVER THE OWNER QUICKLY
OFFERED A REMEDY THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL FOR OTHER RESIDENTS.
MEDICATION AFTER REASSURING
DISCUSSION WE AGREED WITHOUT
KNOWING WE WERE ABOUT TO EXPOSE
MOTHER TO TERROR PRODUCING
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS. MAMA
SPIRALED SHE SWEPT AWAY BY
HALLUCINATIONS OF COLORS AND
BUGS ANIMALS AND DEAD FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH WHOM SHE MADE PLANS
. SHE DEVELOPED ANXIETY FOR
CARING FOR IMAGINARY CHILDREN
SHE LOST HER SENSE OF HUMOR FOR
ABILITY TO REASON OR CONVERSE
EVEN TO TELL SOMEONE SHE NEEDED
WATER OR WAS HURTING. SHE LOST
TOUCH WITH REALITY. SHE WAS ALSO
CONFINED TO A WHEELCHAIR.
HOUSING ATROPHY AND WEIGHT GAIN
WHICH NECESSITATED EXPONENTIALLY
MORE ASSISTANCE. FOR YOUR LEFT
MADE A SEVEN INCH BLISTER ON HER
BACK AND THE CATHETER CAUSED
FREQUENT HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
SERIOUS UT EYES SHE BECAME OUR
BIOTIC RESISTANT AND WE ALMOST
LOST HER SEVERAL TIMES. TRIPS
HOME FOR HOLIDAYS STOPPED MOM
SLEPT ALL THE TIME AS DID ALL
THE OTHER RESIDENTS. MY VIBRANT
MOTHER HAD BEEN REDUCED TO A
SHELL I'M WE THOUGHT IT WAS THE
AGING PROCESS. EVENTUALLY A
RESIDENT ADVOCATE WAS ASSISTING
US. TO HER DRUG LIST AS A
POSSIBLE RED FLAG FOR BAD CARE.
AND WE GOT THE DRUGS
DISCONTINUED. SOON MAMA WAS
AWAKE ALL DAY THE HALLUCINATIONS
STOPPED HER MEMORY SENSE OF
HUMOR AND ABILITY TO REASON WERE
RESTORED SHE INTERACTED WITH
STAFF I'M WITH OTHER RESIDENTS
SHE JOINED ACTIVITIES SHE WAS
SAYING ACTUAL SIZING I'M PLAYING
BINGO. AT NINETY ONE SHE LEARNED
HOW TO PAINT I'M WHATEVER
PICTURES WAS DISPLAYED AT A
LOCAL OUR SHOW. WE COULD BRING
OUR HOME AGAIN FOR HOLIDAYS. AND
WE ENJOYED AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS OF DELIGHT ONLY MAMA COULD
BRING. I WITNESS TO OTHER
RESIDENTS COME BACK TO LIFE AS
WELL WHEN THEY STOP TAKING THESE
DRUGS AND I LEARNED ABOUT
CREATIVE METHODS TO REACH AND
QUIET THE SOULS OF DEMENTIA
PATIENTS USING COLOR AND MUSIC
ARE SIMPLY HAVING A DOLL OR BOTH
THE WHOLE ALL DRUG FREE. RARELY
IN THIS LIFE DO YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP SO MANY
PEOPLE AS PASSING A. B. EIGHTEEN
OH NINE. IT WILL GIVE ALL
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES INFORMED
CHOICE TO REFUSE THE USE OF
DANGEROUS DRUGS AND FRIGHTENING
CHEMICAL RESTRAINT. ON THEIR
LOVED ONES. PLEASE PASS THIS
BILL QUICKLY FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FOR YOUR LOVED ONES
I'M PERHAPS FOR YOURSELF. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
WITNESSES AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SORRY OF SUPPORT IN THAT WELL.
SO WITH THE OPPOSITION OUT
PLEASE I'M SORRY. ARRESTEE BY
RUSTY. I'M GLAD SOMEBODY ELSE IS
RUSTY. WHENEVER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
WE YET WE CAN'T- WE SOME HELP ON
THE- SERGEANTS A FOR MIKE'S NOT
WORKING- MAYBE THE SIGN THAT
SAYS MIKE WITH THE BIG WHITE ON
IT- YEAH YEAH YES IT'S SO IT'S
CLEAR WITH THAT YEAH MY YEAH
YEAH OKAY GOT THAT MY
GRANDPARENTS HI THIS TICKET
SORRY ABOUT THAT JENNIFER SNYDER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH FACILITIES
AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. REGRETFULLY WE- ARE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND IN ITS
CURRENT FORM I'M WHICH FIRST I
VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE AUTHOR
AND OTHER SPONSORS FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH US SO
FAR ON THIS BILL- IT IS- BOTH-
THAT ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES AND C. H. A.'S
INTENT- TO. TO REALLY WORK
THROUGH THE CONCERNS AND THE AND
THE NEEDS- FROM THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS AND SEE WHERE WE
CAN COME TOGETHER ON SOMETHING
THAT WILL WORK IN BOTH CASES I
THINK. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN- MAKING SURE THAT
PATIENTS ARE PROTECTED BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
PRESCRIBERS AND PHYSICIANS- THAT
PROVIDE THE CARE ARE NOT PUT IN
SITUATIONS IN THE NURSING
FACILITIES THEMSELVES BUT I
THINK MORE THE PRESCRIBERS ARE
PUT IN SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
ARE- ARE REQUIRED TO PUT
TOGETHER HUMBER SOME ONEROUS AND
VERY BROAD. WRITTEN CONSENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEN ARE
COUPLED WITH- CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
LIABILITIES THAT ARE ATTACHED TO
AN INCREASE IN INFORMED CONSENT
AIR- AND SO AT LEAST THE WAY
THAT EIGHTEEN OH NINE AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IT DOESN'T
JUST LOOK AT AN ANTI X. IT LOOKS
AT ALL TYPES CYCLE THERAPEUTICS.
IT SAYS IN ALL OF THOSE CASES.
WHAT USED TO DO BUT THE FOR. AND
PATIENT WITH RESPECT TO INFORMED
CONSENT WHERE YOU HAD A GOOD A
DIALOGUE. OR THE PATIENT THE
FAMILY DID MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION. IN THE DISCUSSION WITH
THE PHYSICIAN. WE NOW WANT TO
TAKE ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT USED TO BE A DIALOGUE AND
PUT IT INTO AN INFORMED CONSENT
FORM. NOW AGAIN. THERE MAY BE
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT AS LONG
AS WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
CREATE KIND OF A SITUATION WHERE
THAT INFORMED CONSENT FORM CAN
BE COMPLIED WITH- AND THEN TO
COUPLE THAT WITH A CRIMINAL
BATTERY CHARGE. AND THEN DALY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE CIVIL
PENALTIES ON PRESCRIBERS ARE
CONCERNED FROM NURSING
FACILITIES PERSPECTIVE IS WE
WILL HAVE PRESCRIBERS THAT WHAT
WANT TO CARE FOR PATIENTS AND
WILL HAVE PATIENTS THAT WILL
LOSE ACCESS. IT REALLY NEEDED.
TO PSYCHO THERAPEUTIC DRUGS AND
- A LETTER NEXT WEEK YOU'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE BUT
THOSE THOSE ARE REAL. THAT IS
REALLY WERE CONCERNED LIES SO. I
JUST AM I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- AGAIN I IT WE THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS-
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE. WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
ALREADY- CALIFORNIA SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE. HAS M. IMPROVED OVER 50%
IN THERE- YOU USAGE OF
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS FOR AND
FROM THERE NURSING FACILITY
RIGHT- THAT RESIDENTS WE RANK
THIRD IN THE NATION. IN THAT
USAGE I. CAN'T SAY THAT WE DON'T
NEED TO IMPROVE I CAN'T SAY THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE. AND NEVER WANT TO MAKE
EXCUSES FOR SITUATIONS WHERE
THIS HAPPENED TO HER MOM- I'M
CERTAINLY NOT HERE TO DO THAT
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE A BALANCE SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE. THAT WE PROTECT PATIENTS
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE PATIENTS HAVE
ACCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. YES I AM A
PHYSICIAN AND A AND THE EDITOR
OF THE NEWSLETTER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LONG
TERM CARE MEDICINE. I WANT TO
SHARE MY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL. BECAUSE THE TESTIMONY
WE'VE HEARD IN THE BILL ITSELF
CONCENTRATES ON THE OVER USE OF
ANTI PSYCHOTICS AND I'M NOT
GOING TO ARGUE WITH THAT. IT'S
MY CONCERN IS THE MOST COMMON
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN OLDER
ADULTS AND IN NURSING HOMES. OR
DEPRESSION. ANXIETY DISORDER AND
I WILL TELL US A PRESCRIBER I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO IT HERE TO
THE- REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
TO BE ABLE TO PRESCRIBE ANTI
DEPRESSANTS OR ANTI ANXIETY
DRUGS. BECAUSE OF SIDE EFFECTS
OCCUR. IN VARYING FREQUENCIES N.
I WOULD NOT KNOW WHAT. WHERE THE
LINE IS IT THINGS THAT HAPPENED
ONE IN A HUNDRED IT'S A THINGS
THAT HAPPENED ONE IN A THOUSAND
IS IT A SIDE EFFECT WHICH WAS
RARE IS ONE IN A MILLION. AND
YET THOSE MIGHT BE CONSIDERED
MATERIAL TO INFORMED CONSENT
UNDER THIS BILL AND IF I WAS
WRONG AND LEFT OUT A VERY RARE
SIDE EFFECT. I WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO CRIMINAL PENALTIES SEN IT
WOULD. CLEARLY BE A
DISCOURAGEMENT. AND WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT THE PROVISION OF THESE
KIND OF MENTAL HEALTH DRUGS FOR
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS. IS LOWER
THAN THE NEED IN OTHER WORDS.
THERE'S AN OVER USE OF ANTI
PSYCHOTICS THERE'S AN UNDER USE
OF ANTIDEPRESSANTS AND
TREATMENTS FOR GENERALIZED
ANXIETY DISORDER. AND I THINK
THAT- REALLY EVERY EFFORT TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PRESCRIBERS
TO PRESCRIBE FOR THOSE MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED WHERE IS THISBILL
DOES EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE. THE
SECOND WAY I'M AFRAID THAT THIS
BILL WILL HARM PEOPLE IS
WITHDRAWAL EFFECTS BECAUSE-
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT UNDER
THIS BILL TO DO THE CONSENT
EVERY SIX MONTHS. AND YET AS A
NURSING HOME DOCTOR IT'S COMMON
TO SEE STABLE PATIENTS ABOUT
ONCE A MONTH. AND WHAT I WORRY
ABOUT IS IF YOU FORGET TO GET
INFORMED CONSENT ON THE FIFTH
MONTH. YOU MIGHT EXCEED THE SIX
MONTHS BEFORE YOU VISIT THEM
AGAIN AND THE NURSING HOME WOULD
BE OBLIGED TO STOP THE MEDICINE
ABRUPTLY. WHERE IS THESE ARE ALL
MEDICINES THAT WE NORMALLY PAPER
WHEN WE DISCONTINUED. AND IF YOU
ABRUPTLY STOP THEM THEY'RE
REALLY ASSOCIATED WITH SIDE
EFFECTS AND SO I'M CONCERNED
THAT THESE COMMON CONDITIONS AND
I'M SURE YOU DEPRESSION IS
COMMON. WILL CLOSE FOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND FOR THE RECORD DR
COULD YOU WOULD YOU MIND GIVING
US YOUR NAME OKAY LUXEMBOURG
THANK YOU FOR SHE IS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW GO TO-
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM OF
PLEASE COME FORWARD JUST WITH
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. YES MEAN OUR SYSTEM. OR NOW
HISTORY. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
HI YES MAIN PAYLOAD ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE IN AGING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RUSSELL
KALIAN YANG REPRESENTING SUPER
SENIORS NETWORK WORKING WITH THE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARTICLE
YAMADA AND ALSO REPRESENTING
SHALL FLOODED IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CLINTON LACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINA HILDERBRAND FROM
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT BUT WE WOULD LIKE A
CONSERVATORSHIP SAID DRESSED IN
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM EITHER FOR OR AGAINST JUST
YOUR NAME. I'M SORRY. THE CARD.
APPARENTLY NOT OKAY ALL RIGHT
BYE CORRECTIVE. NO MORE OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU SO AT THIS
POINT- WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- FOR OTHERS- WHEN IF
THEY'RE I HAVEN'T HEARD THE
OPERATOR YET SO I ASSUME THERE'S
NOT A FREIGHTER THERE. I SHOULD
ASSUME ANYTHING. I SO- MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST THEIR
NAME POSITION AND ON THE BILL OR
AN ORGANIZATON THEY REPRESENT
ONE. GIVE HER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE IS
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOYS CATTLEMEN AT WORK SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO- NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR MACE. YEAH LET'S ADD TO THAT
BUTTON WITH MI SEE ON IT YEAH
THERE WE GO. THIS IS FANCY.
SUPER FANCY THEY DID A GREAT JOB
AS MY FIRST COMMITTEE HEARING HE
DID A GREAT JOB WITH THIS- WITH
THIS- FACILITY- SO- HUH I THINK
IT A BIT LOOKING AT THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
IN THIS IS THE THESE WERE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS YOU'RE GONNA
BE WORKING A WORKING THROUGH-
ALL OF IT- I HAVE- ENDED UP-
MARRYING A PROVIDER DENTISTRY OF
COURSE NOT- IN. IT'S NOT A
PHYSICIAN AND DOESN'T WORK IN A-
HEALTH FACILITY. I LEARNED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- CONSENT FORMS
AND SORT OF THE PROCESS OF ALL
OF THAT. AND THERE IS A SENSE
AMONG PROVIDERS WHO HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS. VERY QUICKLY- WHETHER
YOU'RE MAKING A RIGHT DECISION
OR- A WRONG DECISION. AND THE
THOUGHT OF BEING CHARGED WITH A
CRIMINAL. OFFENSE FOR- FOR THEIR
PROFESSIONAL BEHAVIOR IS PRETTY
STRONG- AND SO IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. A WIDER DID GET IN THE
BILL IN THE FIT IN THE FIRST
PLACE IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
NECESSARY- IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT PROVISION I UNDERSTAND IF
YOU'RE GOING TO. DO SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ENFORCEMENT MAC ISM BUT- AS A
SEATS PRETTY STRONG. WILL LOBBY
THE FIRST DEGREE THAT THE
BATTERY ISN'T THE CORRECT
PENALTY THAT WE HAVE IN THE BILL
AS IT IS NOW. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT DURING
THE NEXT COMMUNITY WHEN WE GO TO
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY. AND
WE'LL FIGURE OUT WHAT OF-
PENALTIES ARE APPROPRIATE. SO AT
THAT TIME WE WILL GO WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AND SO AS YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
THIS AS WELL- IT AGAIN BUT I
THINK PART OF IT IS YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROVIDERS
RE. PROVIDE I MEAN THERE'S BAD
ACTORS YEAH THERE THERE'S A
HUNDRED YEAH FOR SURE THOSE BAD
ACTORS- AND SO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME SORT OF
MECHANISM FOR THE SAME TIME YOU
DON'T WANT TO. DETER PROVIDERS-
YOU KNOW PHYSICIANS FOR MAKING
DECISIONS BECAUSE IF THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE MAKING
A DECISION. THAT THEY'RE GONNA
LOSE OUR LICENSES THEY'RE GONNA
END UP IN A IN IN IN JAIL OR
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE THAT IT
ENDS UP HAVING A CHILLING EFFECT
ON THE CARE THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
TO PROVIDE. AND SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
CAREFUL OF THAT. ABSOLUTELY
REJECT MAKE INCOME. BUT
ABSOLUTELY AGREE- THE IDEAS.
HAVING APPROPRIATE
PROPORTIONALITY. OF IF IT'S IF
IT'S A PRESCRIBERS MADE AN-
HONEST MISTAKE. PAPERWORK AIR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THERE'S NO
CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR THAT BUT
FOR THOSE WHO. AND YOU KNOW FOR
LOTS AND LOTS OF RESIDENTS ARE
PRESCRIBED MAKING PRESCRIPTIONS
FOR DRUGS THAT THEY PROBABLY
DON'T NEED AND THAT PROBABLY
HURT THEM IF THAT'S A PATTERN
AND PRACTICE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MADE. YOU KNOW
REQUIRE SOME SORT OF SIGNIFICANT
PENALTY. IT AND THEN JUST FINE
I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIR JUST YOU
KNOW IT IN REGARDS TO THE
INFORMED CONSENT AS WELL. ALL OF
US WHEN WE GO TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO THE DOCTOR WE GO TO THE
DENTIST WE GET A STACK OF
PAPERWORK. AND WE GO THROUGH IT
I MEAN WHO READS ALL OF IT. I
MEAN REALLY WHO READS WHO READS
ALL OF THAT AND THE LONGER THAT
IT IS THE LESS INCLINED YOU ARE
TO ACTUALLY. THAT TO BE ABLE TO
READ IT AND SO YOU KNOW PART OF
THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA. OF CONSENT
FORM YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE IT'S
VERY SIMPLE AND- AND THAT IT'S
NOT TOO OVERLY COMPLICATED
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S JUST- IF YOU
HAVE TOO MUCH OF IT PEOPLE JUST
SIGNED SIGNED AWAY SIGN A LIFE
AWAY- I'M LITERALLY- I THINK-
SIGN SIGN THEIR LIFE AWAY. JUST
AS A QUICK ASIDE IT BUT- YOU
KNOW. THAT AT THE TWELVE WEEK
OLD. TODAY AS OF THE END IN
DECEMBER- WHILE WE WERE IN THE
HOSPITAL'S PRETTY FAST NAY LOWER
IN THE HOSPITAL. WAITING FOR. A
BABY. TO COME. AS THE AT THE
FACILITY- EVERY. FIVE MINUTES
SOMEBODY'S. COMING IN WITH AN
IPAD SAYING SIGN HERE SIGN HERE
SIGN HERE. IF NOT IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE SIGNING IS YOUR- IF
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH THIS YEAR
THEY'RE IN PAIN OR GOING THROUGH
SO. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WERE. CAREFUL ABOUT SORT OF THE
PROCESS. OF ALL THIS IS WELL-
AND SOMETIMES WE MAKE LAWS TO
THIS. AND WE CAN BE IT CAN BE
TOUGH TO AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES I JUST I
WANNA AGREE WITH YOU YOU KNOW
THE- THE KEY IS TO BE MINDFUL.
AND THOUGHTFUL IN HOW WE DO
THIS. AS WE HAVE SO MANY OF OUR
LOVED ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
HOMES. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SAFE. AND OF THIS IS
JUST REALLY COME TO THE SURFACE
ARE QUITE. A BIT LATELY WITH THE
QUOTE DURING COVERT. FRIENDS OF-MINE HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS.
AND SO REALLY KIND OF HIT HOME
AND THIS IS APPROPRIATE TIME. OF
GRANTED I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS TO FINE TUNE IT AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE ALL HAVE GOOD.
RELATIONSHIPS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. WITH MISS
WALDRON. VICE CHAIR. WALDRON
ANOTHER WAY WE'VE HAD A CHANGE
OF CARE SO. THAT A VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. I
FIGURE OUT THE MICROPHONE. NO I
JUST WANNA PICKING BACK OFF OF
OUR OUR COLLEAGUES- COMMENTS. AS
WELL AND- IT IS AN ISSUE BUT AS
WAS MENTIONED IT WOULD IT'S BEEN
REDUCED- QUITE A BIT IN
CALIFORNIA I HAD AN AUNT WHO WAS
IN HER LATE EIGHTIES FOUND
WANDERING. OF IMMEDIATELY WHEN
SHE WENT INTO THE NURSING HOME
WAS PUT ON THOSE DRUGS. AND
CHANGED. YOU KNOW IN MANY WAYS
BUT LUCKILY SHE HAD THE SENSE OF
MIND BEFORE ALL OF THIS TO HAVE
MY BROTHER B. I HAVE POWER OF
ATTORNEY. WHO'S A PHYSICIAN HE
WENT IN ON RIVALED EVERYTHING
NOT JUST DRUGS. THE MONEY
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAD GONE IN
AND TAKEN EVERYTHING- BUT IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE. EVERYONE UP
HERE IS AN AGREEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO REDUCE THE USE OF
CONTROL HOW IT'S DONE GET THE
APPROPRIATE PROCESS TO SIGN YOU
KNOW THESE PAPERS AND NOT MAKE
IT. WORTH A PHYSICIAN YOU KNOW
IS GOING TO PRISON OR LOSING THE
LICENSE OVER SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE JUST A- AN HONEST
MISTAKE. BUT- I LOOK FORWARD TO.
YOU ALL WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS
AND- COMING TO A SOLUTION THAT
HELPS THE PATIENT. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE I WOULD
JUST I GUESS I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY- I KIND OF A LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING HERE TOO AS A SOMEONE
WHO WAS A PRACTITIONER FOR
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS- AND DEL ON
A DAILY BASIS- MULTIPLE TIMES
WITH INFORMED CONSENT IT WHAT
MOTIVATED ME WAS NUMBER ONE. THE
PATIENT MAKING SURE THEY
UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WERE WE WERE DOING AND WHAT THE
POTENTIAL RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT
BUT THE HAMMER ON THE OTHER END
FOR ME WAS THE THREAT OF A
LAWSUIT AND SO- I DID WANT TO
GET SUED BASED ON MY CONDUCT OR
MY LACK OF CONDUCT SO- SO YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
A YOU KNOW THERE'S A FINE LINE
HERE NOW ON THE OTHER HAND WHEN
YOU GOT A REPEAT OFFENDER YOU
KNOW AND EGREGIOUS VIOLATION OF-
PAY A PATIENTS RIGHTS THAT'S A
DIFFERENT AND- AND I THINK. MY
SENSES THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET TO IS IT IS YOU KNOW EVEN
IN THE BEST A WORLD THAT
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW- AND INFORMED
CONSENT TO ONE PERSON MAY NOT BE
TO ANOTHER AND SO THERE'S A
CHALLENGE THERE'S A CHALLENGE
WITH THAT AS WELL. ANYWAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MISS JERRY
TALKING EVERY TAKING AMENDMENTS
THE OTHER ARE WE ADDING ASKING
FOR THERE ARE AMENDMENTS. SHE
HAS ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS YES- AND- SO I THINK
YOU'LL SEE WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM HERE SO WE'D BE THERE IS
NO THERE IS NO MOTION AT THIS
POINT IT WILL IT TOO I DO.
RECOMMENDATION WHEN THAT TO BE
RIGHT SO- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE US ASSEMBLY AUSTRIA RIVAL
IN THE TIMES APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN A MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU TO WITNESSES AS WELL. AFTER
ARAMBULA. A REGULAR HAS TWO
BILLS BEFORE US AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED AND AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE AND START WITH AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. AB NINETEEN HUNDRED
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
OLDER AND DISABLED TO KEEP MORE
OF THEIR MONEY EXCUSE ME MORE OF
THEIR MONTHLY INCOME TO PAY FOR
NECESSITIES LIKE FOOD CLOTHES
AND SHELTER WHILE STILL
QUALIFYING FOR MEDICAL. DESPITE
OUR HIGH COST OF LIVING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE TRAILED BEHIND
SEVERAL STATES AND HOW MUCH
PEOPLE IN CERTAIN MEDICAL
PROGRAMS MUST PAY FOR THEIR OWN
HEALTH CARE BEFORE MEDICARE
KICKS IN. TODAY OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES FOR
JUST ONE DOLLAR OVER THE FREE
MEDICAL LIMIT ARE FORCED TO
SURVIVE ON JUST SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO PAY FOR THE RENT FOR
THEIR FOOD AND THEIR UTILITIES
AS WELL AS ALL OF THEIR OTHER
EXPENSES. THIS PROGRAM HAS NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AN OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
PAYING THE PRICE. THIS IS SIMPLY
A MATTER OF FAIRNESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AND NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. HI MAKING
THIS MUCH NEEDED ADJUSTMENT WITH
AB NINETEEN HUNDRED WE CAN HELP
TO EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDENS.
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT CHOOSING
BETWEEN THE NEED FOR MEDICAL
ATTENTION AND THE NEED TO PAY
FOR RENT TENDS TO BUY FOOD. IT
IS TIME FOR US TO DITCH THE
DEDUCTIBLE AND TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A LEADER IN MEDIC
CALIFORNIA BILITY FOR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
TEAM HUNDRED ARE SO WHITE SAY
YOU FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS BE LET YOU
AGAIN. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THINGS ARE DIFFERENT HERE
TODAY. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO WHITE C. M. ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE THE
DESIGNATED PROTECTION AND
ADVOCACY AGENCY FOR CALIFORNIA
MANDATED TO ADVANCE THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA SHARED THE SHARE OF
COST PROGRAM ACTS AS A CRITICAL
PATHWAY TO HEALTH COVERAGE FOR
LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WHO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH CARE
NEEDS BUT ARE JUST ABOVE THE
FREE MEDIC CAL INCOME LIMIT. THE
OUTDATED INCOME LIMITS HAVE
FORCED PEOPLE TO SPEND MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME ON HEALTH
CARE NEEDS EVERY MONTH. THE
RESULT OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE PUSHED
INTO EXTREME POVERTY AND SOME
JUST FORGO CARE ENTIRELY BECAUSE
IT'S JUST TOO EXPENSIVE. THIS
MEANS NO DENTAL COVERAGE NO
SERVICES NO SUPPORTS TO HELP YOU
REMAIN IN YOUR HOME. AND NO
COVERAGE FOR ANYTHING AT ALL IF
YOU'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
. THINK ABOUT IT COULD YOU LIVE
ON SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT'S WHAT THE PROGRAM DEMANDS
OF OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO NEED CARE. WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T ACCESS HEALTH AT
HOME CARE THEY OFTEN END UP
HOSPITALIZED OR
INSTITUTIONALIZED OR HAVE TO
RELY ON ALREADY STRETCHED FAMILY
MEMBERS TO PROVIDE UNPAID CARE.
THIS IS ALSO AN EQUITY ISSUE
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
THE ONLY POPULATION FORCED TO
PAY SO MUCH TO OBTAIN ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE. MOST LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THEIR HEALTH
CARE FOR FREE. AND AT MOST DO
NOT HAVE TO PAY MORE THAN EIGHT
POINT 5% OF THEIR INCOME ON
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. YET LOW
INCOME OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES HER ONLY A
DOLLAR OVER THE LIMIT FOR FREE
MEDIKAL AND LIVE ON FIXED
INCOMES ARE EXPECTED TO PAY 60%
OF THEIR MONTHLY INCOME ON
HEALTH CARE EXPENSES. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA SHARED
IT REALLY IS TIME TO DITCH THE
DEDUCTIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED I'M BAILEY
AGAIN A LONG TERM CARE ADVOCATE
WITH CALIFORNIA TICKETS FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS ON BEHALF OF
A CLIENT OF MINE- WHO ISN'T ABLE
TO APPEAR IN PERSON HER NAME IS
NOT THE SHEPHERDING AND THIS IS
ABOUT HER PARENTS JOSE AND LISA.
NOT THE COLOR OFFICES TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY
FOR HER FATHER JOSE WHO IS
SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD AND HER
MOTHER LISA WHO IS SEVENTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD. BOTH OF THEM ARE
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR OVER
FIFTY FOUR YEARS WAS A WORK TWO
JOBS AND AFTER FORTY ONE YEARS
OF WORKING HE RETIRED. SHORTLY
AFTER RELEASE TO BEGIN CHAU
EARLY SIGNS OF ALZHEIMER'S AND
RELIED ON JOSE AS HER PRIMARY
CAREGIVER UNTIL HIS HEALTH
STARTED TO DECLINE AS WELL. NOT
BEEN RESERVING HOPE TO FIND IN
HOME SUPPORT THROUGH MEDIC CAL
FOR BOTH OF HER PARENTS. HOUSE
IN A LEASE YES TOTAL MONTHLY
INCOME IS TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH PUTS THEM
ABOVE THE 110038% FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL FOR A COUPLE.
MEANING THAT IF THEY APPLY FOR
MEDICAL TOGETHER THEY WILL HAVE
A SHARE OF COST. THE PROBLEM IS
THEIR SHARE OF COST WOULD BE ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
DOLLARS BECAUSE THE MAINTENANCE
NEEDS LEVEL FOR A COUPLE. IS
ONLY NINE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS. THIS LEAVES JOSE IN A
LEASE SALE WITHOUT ENOUGH MONEY
TO PAY FOR OTHER NECESSITIES
SUCH AS RENT. FOOD OR UTILITIES.
NOT THE AND HER SIBLINGS ARE
ALREADY HELPING WITH THE BILLS
BUT WITH THE SHERIFF COSTS THAT
HIGH THE FAMILY COULD NOT
AFFORD. FOR BOTH PARENTS TO
APPLY FOR MEDICAL. IN ORDER TO
AVOID A HUGE SHARE OF COST THE
ONLY OPTION FOR NOT THESE
PARENTS WOULD BE TO PRIORITIZE.
THE PARENT WITH THE HIGHER NEED.
AND SUBMIT A MEDICAL APPLICATION
SEEKING SPOUSAL IMPOVERISHMENT
PROTECTIONS. ALTHOUGH HER MOM
REQUIRES A LOT OF CARE THE
FAMILY DECIDED TO ONLY HAVE JOSE
APPLY AS HIS HEALTH WAS
DECLINING RAPIDLY. THIS IS A
COMMON PROBLEM THAT I'VE COME
ACROSS DURING MY TIME I CAN'T
AWARE FAMILIES HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN WHICH PARENT RECEIVES
CARE. BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD
THE SHERIFF COST. IF THE
MAINTENANCE NEED LEVELS INCREASE
TO MATCH THE 110030% FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. POSING A LEASE.
OF WOULD ONLY BE THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR DOLLARS. WHICH WOULD
BE A LOT MORE FEASIBLE FOR NOT
THIS FAMILY AND WOULD ALLOW
BOTH. JSE LEE SAID RECEIVE
SERVICES THROUGH MEDIC CAL.
INCREASING THE MAINTENANCE THE
LEVEL WOULD ALLOW OLDER AND
DISABLED CALIFORNIANS ACCESS. TO
NECESSARY KERR WILL KEEPING MORE
MONEY TO REMAIN IN THE
COMMUNITY. NOT THE SAYS I'M
ASKING FOR REFORM OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT ADDRESSES
THE MEDICAL NEEDS OF MINORITY
GROUPS LIKE MY PARENTS. THESE
ARE MY PARENTS THEY HAVE RAISE
GREAT CHILDREN AND THEY DESERVE
TO ENJOY THEIR FAMILY
RETIREMENT. FOR THIS REASON I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO FULL AYE
ON AP NINETEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
. THANK YOU WERE GOING TO STOP
FOR A SECOND- WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT. AMOUNT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT. YEAR WALDRON. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BIGELOW. FOR REAL. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY THIS
AREA. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO. SHE'S
MAKE THEM WHEN THE BUT HERE
WITHOUT GO TO. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. C. NINE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
COULD LIKE TO TESTIFY JUST YOUR
NAME OPPOSITION ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE. I'LL START
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF ASKING ON BEHALF OF
CAL PACE THE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF. PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
IN SUPPORT. YOU YES MEAN PALETTE
ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN AGING A
CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. KELLY BRETT KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF y
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CORNERS WITH. CONOR SWEENEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES HERE IN
SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE I WILL GO TO THE
FRONT LINES MADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. H.
AND AFTERNOON SHERRY BURNS- THE
CHAIRED THE AGM SERVICES
COLLABORATIVE IN THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SPPORT INTEGRATION
COMMITTEES FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU
TURN MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING ALZHEIMER'S BALLET
ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE COUNTY AND
ALZHEIMER'S CAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN
GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH THERE BUT ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ITS COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAN OPEN BOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE BILL ONE
NINE ZERO ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
RENEE BLACKWELL AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
AND WE WERE EIGHTY NINETEEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PREPPING YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER SHALL DENTALS ON BEHALF
OF PETER W. LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN AND GO WITH
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE AT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURGEONING
SOME OF THEM DR ST PAUL GET
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IN
CALLING AT THE PORT AB NINE
HUNDRED PEOPLE LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
ITSELF THANK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CAN MEMBERS TO
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARCANE
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME I THOUGHT
I WILL GET THAT AND I AND THE
LAST ADVOCACY MANAGER WITH THE
FOOTBALL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS JOSE
TORRES WITH HEALTH ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DISTILLED COMMITTEE
ADVOCATE FOR THE JORDAN VALLEY
AND DEVELOPMENT CENTER IF
SUPPORT AND AB NINETEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHOSEN TANPA
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGAL AID
SOCIETY OF SAN MATTEO COUNTY
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
JOYCE CANAVAN ON BEHALF OF
SENIOR ADVOCACY NETWORK IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY AND THE STAFF
OF COUNTY COMMISSION ON AGING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY SIXTY LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CAMMY CAME CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MEALS ON WHEELS ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN CONTRACT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CALIFON
FROM THE SENATE LEGAL SERVICES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONLINE SIXTY SIXTY LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M REBEKAH COUSINS ON
THE VOLUNTEER WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU- ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
ONE MORE IN Q. BUT WITH THE GIVE
THEIR LINE NUMBER. NO JUST BE
ONE MORE MOMENT HERE. THANK YOU
AND I LAST WILL COME FROM NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MATTHEW DEPARTMENT THE MARIN
PENETRATE DEPENDING AND WE CAN
GET THE SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THAT- HAVE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER. COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. THE.
OKAY S WE HAVE A WEEK WE HAVE A
MOTION- SECOND THE MOTION WOULD
BE DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS-
WHICH I TO CLOSE DOCTOR AND DO.
SPECTRALLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND- A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA AYE
RAMBLE AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING. CORREO. LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MAYES MCCARTY NAZARIAN REALIST
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
YOUR FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL AND SHOULD THE BILL
PASS OUT OF COMMITTEE I'D LIKE
TO ASK FOR TO BE CONSIDERED AS A
CO AUTHOR ON YOUR BILL SOUNDS
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YES
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR NEXT BILL AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AB NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE WILL ENSURE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS CAN ACCESS
HEALTHCARE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. TO STAY HEALTHY AND THRIVE
BY ELIMINATING THEIR MONTHLY
MEDICAL PREMIUMS. AND
COPAYMENTS. DURING MY YEARS AS
AN EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIAN. I
SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES THAT DELAYED MEDICAL
CARE. BECAUSE THEY HAD NO ACCESS
TO HEALTH INSURANCE. OR HAD LOST
THEIR INSURANCE. THE
CONSEQUENCES WERE SEVERE.
DEVASTATING OR WORST. WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM SO THAT
PREGNANT WOMEN CHILDREN AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES CAN BE
ASSURED THAT THEIR MEDICAL
COVERAGE CONTINUES AND THAT THEY
WON'T HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE OR
PAYING FOR HOUSEHOLD BILLS.
MEDICAL PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS
ARE A RELIC OF THE PAST. IT IS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHERE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IS GOING WHICH IS
TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE. IT ALSO
FLIES CONTRARY TO CALIFORNIA'S
GOALS IN TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THREATENS THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
AB NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WILL
SOLVE THIS ISSUE BY ELIMINATING
THE MEDIC CAL COPAYMENTS AND
PREMIUMS FOR PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS CHILDREN AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE ARCADY ANDREW THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH AT CHILDREN
NOW AS WELL AS LINDA WAY THE
SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE AT
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHERRY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
IMPORTANT IMPACT THAT AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WOULD HAVE
ON THE LIVES OF NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
LOW INCOME CHILDREN PREGNANT
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BY ELIMINATING
MEDICAL PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS
. FOUR CHILDREN MEDICAL COVERAGE
PROVIDES FREE OR LOW COST HEALTH
COVERAGE THAT HELPS IMPROVE
HEALTH REDUCE DISABILITY AND
INCREASED EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
AND ECONOMIC STABILITY. HOWEVER
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN PREGNANT PEOPLE AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE ON THE HOOK FOR MONTHLY
PREMIUMS THAT DO NOT YIELD TO
NIC SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS FOR
THE STATE. BUT DO CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC BURDEN FOR
PEOPLE ALREADY. STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY. OFTEN LEADING
FAMILIES TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING THEIR PREMIUMS OR PAYING
FOR OTHER BASIC NECESSITIES LIKE
FOOD RENT AND DIAPERS. BY
ELIMINATING MONTHLY MEDICARE
PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS AB IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WILL NOT
ONLY ALLEVIATE THESE IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
BUT WILL ALSO RESULT IN REDUCED
COVERAGE CHURN IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
ELIMINATING MEDICAL PREMIUMS AND
MEDIKAL- SORRY ELIMINATING
PREMIUMS A MEDIC CAL PROMOTES
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND PROMOTES EQUITY
BETWEEN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
COVERAGE. LAST YEAR LAWMAKERS
ALLOCATED FUNDING TO PROVIDE
ZERO DOLLAR COVERAGE FOR CAL OF
COVERED CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
NOTING THAT EVEN NOMINAL COST TO
TURN ROMAN IN AND UTILIZATION OF
HEALTH COVERAGE. MEDIC HOW KIDS
AND FAMILIES DESERVE THE SAME
RELIEF. AND PROTECTION. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE PROPOSED
BUDGET AND SUBSEQUENT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO REDUCE TO ZERO
MEDICAL PREMIUMS WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS LANGUAGE GOES
FAR ENOUGH LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN
FOR A FUTURE ADMINISTRATION TO
REINSTATE MEDIC HELP PREMIUM AND
COPAYMENT REQUIREMENTS. THIS IS
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THAT
THE FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO PAY MEDICAL
PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS ARE
LIKELY TO BE IT BE HIT THE
HARDEST BY AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES IN THE NATION
TO REQUIRE CHILDREN IN MEDICAID
TO PAY PREMIUMS FOR COVERAGE
GOING AGAINST WHAT OUR GREAT
STATE TOUTS IS A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS.
COMPLETE ELIMINATING MEDICAL
PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS FOR
ALREADY STRUGGLING FAMILIES AND
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES WILL
BRING US ONE STEP CLOSER TO A
MORE JUST HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS LED AWAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHICH WOULD
ELIMINATE MEDICARE PREMIUMS AND
COPAYMENTS. TO ENSURE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS CAN ACCESS NEEDED
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. WHAT
DISABILITIES MEDICARE ALLOWS
THEM TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AVOID COSTLY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION EVEN WITH
INCOMES BELOW TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
A MONTH PEOPLE WORKING PART TIME
ARE STILL EXPECTED TO PAY UP TO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN
MONTHLY. MEDICARE PREMIUMS THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO KEEP MORE OF
THEIR INCOME ON BASIC
NECESSITIES. IN ADDITION AB
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WOULD
ELIMINATE COPAYMENTS AS THERE IS
NO FINANCIAL OR POLICY REASON TO
KEEP IN STATUTE. COPAYMENTS ACT
AS A POTENTIAL BARRIER TO CARE
AND ARE CURRENTLY NOT
ENFORCEABLE AND RARELY IF EVER
COLLECTED BY PROVIDERS THIS BILL
HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION AND URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
THANK YOU AT THE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT- IN THE ROOM PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE THANK YOU FOR
ASKING ON BEHALF THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP PARENTS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KATEY
LEIGHTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THE WHITE C. M. ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. YOU. YES MEAN PELLET ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN AGING AND
SUPPORT YOUR- KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE ACCOUNT WELL FOR
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THAT
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS ON SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF CAN I
HELP NOT A CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
WELLNESS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BAILEY YOU CAN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOMES REFORM AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO MADDEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AT ONE FOUR BONTA
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HEY I GOT ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WHEN I GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- AND ASK THE
OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST THEIR
NAME POSITION AN ORGANIZATION IF
THEY REPRESENT ONE. THANK YOU
FOR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON
A. B. NINETEEN NINETY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF A BEAT NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
FOR THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU RIGHT
CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHNSON GO NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING
STRONG SUPPORTER AB. EIGHT
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH
YES I THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DURING A WALK FROM
ASIAN RESEARCHERS AIN'T IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY MARKETS WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WELL I AM AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS SOME OF THEM DON'T
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
BARBARA PILOT YOUNG INVINCIBLES
AGAIN HEARING SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AMY BLOOMBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY BURNS WITH
AGENT SERVICES COLLABORATIVE AND
LONG TRM SERVICES AND SUPPORT
FOR SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO
YOU HAVE A SON YOU. HELLO THIS
IS- JOE IS A TERRIBLE LEGAL AID
SOCIETY CEMETERY ACCOUNTING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MANY
BROWN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WHERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHITE EIGHTY TWO DO YOU HAVE A
SOME MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE AT NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE TERM
MEMBER GOOD AFTERNOON THERESA
ANDERSON WITH THE ARK AND UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND THE LAST ONE IN Q. WE
HAVE IS EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN'S
GIRLFRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
JUST HAVE A QUICK COMMENT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND YOU I LOVE THESE TWO
BILLS THAT YOU'VE JUST DONE.
WE'RE CHANGING PEOPLE'S LIVES
ARE GETTING MONEY BACK IN THEIR
POCKET FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THAT EXTRA. TEN FIFTEEN DOLLARS
IN THIS ALL COMES TOGETHER IN
THESE ARE VERY MEANINGFUL BILLS
AND MINDFUL I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
YOUR CHANGES IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THIS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE WITH THE
GOVERNOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. MISTER BIGELOW-
I WANT TO ECHO THOSE COMMENTS.
ARE THAT WERE JUST MADE RIGHT
THERE BUT I ALSO HAVE DOUBTS THE
TOUGHER QUESTION WHICH IS. WE'RE
NOT ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE A
SURPLUS SO HOW DO YOU. PROPOSE
AND THIS MAY BE WHEN IT GETS
DOWN TO APPROACH ARE WE REALLY.
A FOR THIS THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE TOP. ISSUE FOR YOU THIS BILL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS ON
BUDGET- AS THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE ALL FOCUS ON THE
POLICY THAT'S BEFORE US- SERVING
AS THE CHAIR OF. BUDGET SUB ONE
I'M INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT I NEED FOR US TO SHARE OUR
POLICY AND BUDGET- BE A GOALS
TOGETHER AND TO LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION BUT SIMPLY
WOULD. POINT OUT THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN INVESTING
RESOURCES TO ATTEMPT TO COLLECT
MONEY MANY OF THESE PREMIUMS
AND- OUT REALLY AREN'T SEEING
THAT MUCH OF A- SAVINGS- IN
TERMS OF THE BENEFIT WE COULD
GIVE TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ACT AS YOU AND I
BOTH SAID ON THOSE TYPES OF
COMMITTEES. AND THAT MAKES IT
HARD TO THAT YOU KNOW FOR US WE
HAVE TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AND
I KNOW TODAY IS A POLICY.
COMMITTEE AND ALL WAIT TO VOTE
REALLY ON IT WHEN I GUESS POLICY
COMMITTEE- TO BE FAIR TO US I
DON'T BRIDGES THAT- BUT THE
REALITY. IS THERE'S PROBABLY A
GOOD ANSWER IN THE LATTER PART
OF YOUR DISCUSSION THERE AND
THAT IS. THE SAVINGS WILL
PROBABLY. BE RECOGNIZED. IN THE
FACT THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCOLLECTIBLE SAID ARE. POSSIBLY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE COLLECTED
THAT'LL COVER THE DEBT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE NONE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO YOU DR ED
BILL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
WANNA BUILD OFF OF WHAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY HAD
SAID HOE IS ON THE HORIZON FOR
MANY OF US AND- I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR ABILITY AS A LEGISLATURE
TO PASS BILLS JUST LIKE THIS.
MAKE THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
BETTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THE MOTION
BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ- SECOND BY
MISTAKE YOUR CURRY DID YOU IT
HAVE YOU ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
I HAVEN'T OKAY. JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION YOU KNOW. OKAY HI
I. ANYWAY I'M RUSTY STILL HAVE
BEEN A RUSTY ALL DAY. SO SO THE
MEASURE THE MOTION IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CARILLO LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. OH I'M SORRY
MCCARTY I. NAZARIAN RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO. HI FIVE WILL HAVE WILL BE
BELIEVING YOUR BILL ON CALL
DOCTOR REGULAR- THIS
BOERNER HORVATH- THE RUMOR THAT
YOU WERE GONNA LET TALK MR
LEVINE- FORCES CORRECT. YOU'RE
SERIOUS- OKAY. WELL IT SO IT'S
NOT REALLY RIVER THAN MR LEVINE
PLEASE COME FOR. IT'S ALMOST NOT
BELIEVABLE UNLESS IT COMES FROM
THE NUMBER THAT WHILE SHE WAS
SITTING RIGHT THERE AND YOU KNOW
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT. GOOD
pMEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THINKING THE
CHAIR AND ALSO YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE
NOT JUST ON THIS BILL BUT- ON
THIS ISSUE THAT GOES BACK MANY
YEARS- THANK YOU AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT EFFORT. AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS WITH MEDICAL COVERAGE
TO RETURN HOME. WHEN THEY'RE
READY AND HAVE A HOME TO RETURN
TO. MEDICAL PROVIDES COVERAGE TO
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS FOR
NURSING HOME CARE. HOWEVER
INDIVIDUALS WITH MEDIC CAL IN
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES ARE AT
RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES.
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
INCOME IS PAID FOR A SHARE OF
THE COST TO THE NURSING HOME.
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS HALLMARK
LONG TERM CARE MEDICARE MUST PAY
A MONTHLY SHARE OF COST EQUAL.
THEY'RE GROSSLY MONTHLY INCOME
AND ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO KEEP
PERSONAL AN INCIDENTAL NEEDS
ALLOWANCE. OF THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER MONTH. THESE
PATIENTS MAY QUALIFY FOR A
LITTLE KNOWN MEDIKAL DEDUCTION
CALLED THE HOME UPKEEP
ALLOWANCE. THE H. U. A. ENABLES
THE PERSON TO KEEP TWO HUNDRED
NINE DOLLARS A MONTH OF THEIR
INCOME FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND
UPKEEP OF THEIR HOME. WHILE THEY
ARE TEMPORARILY RESIDING IN THE
NURSING HOME OR OTHER MEDICAL
FACILITY. THEY THREE CAN BE
ALLOWED FOR UP TO A SIX MONTH
PERIOD. FROM THE DATE THE PERSON
ENTERS THE FACILITY HOWEVER.
HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS- IN AMOUNT
HAS NOT BEEN CHANGED IN DECADES
THE ALLOWANCE AMOUNT IS
INADEQUATE TO PAY. THE RENT OR
MORTGAGE ANOTHER COST NEEDED TO
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN A HOME OR
APARTMENT. AND AVAILABILITY OF
THIS OPTION IS NOT WIDELY KNOWN
THIS RESULTS IN PEOPLE. THING IN
NURSING HOMES INDEFINITELY
BECAUSE THEY LOSE THEIR HOME.
AND ARE UNABLE TO TRANSITION
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY. THIS
BILL. WILL MAKE THE H. U. A. A
MEANINGFUL BENEFIT. BY
INCREASING THE AMOUNT TO THE
ACTUAL MINIMUM COST OF
MAINTAINING THE HOME INCLUDING
MORTGAGE. PROPERTY TAXES UTILITY
AND REQUIRED INSURANCE. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO IMPROVE PUBLIC
AWARENESS OFTHE PROGRAM TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION BY
REQUIRING THE STATE TO PUBLICIZE
THE H. UA. AND ESTABLISH A CLEAR
APPLICATION PROCESS WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO CREATE A TRANSITIONAL
NEEDS ALLOWANCE. TO ALLOW A
PARTY TO ASSIST PEOPLE LIVING IN
LONG TERM TERM CARE FACILITIES.
WHO DO NOT HAVE A HOME TO RETURN
TO. AFFORD A HOME IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND LEAVE LONG TERM
CARE. WHEN THEY ARE READY. THIS
BENEFIT HAS NOT BEEN INCREASED
IN FAR TOO LONG AND DOES NOT
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S COST OF
LIVING. THIS BILL IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE
HOMES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
RETURN TO. WHEN EXITING CARE.
AND I HAVE TO- AMAZING WITNESSES
NEXT TO ME- TO SPEAK TO THIS
POINT I'VE SWAYED ASYLUMS FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND BELA YOU GUN CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE WHITE
SEA AGAIN ON DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. TRYING TO GET USED
TO THIS NEW SET UP- SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
RECEIVING REHABILITATION OR CARE
AND NURSING FACILITIES ARE AT
RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE WAS
SHARING. I'M THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROBLEMS WITH THE CURRENT HOME
UPKEEP ALLOWANCE ONE IT'S ONLY
TWO HUNDRED AND NINE DOLLARS A
MONTH AN AMOUNT UNCHANGED SINCE
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. IT'S
TOTALLY INSUFFICIENT FOR THE
COST OF LIVING IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. TO THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
ALLOWANCE IS NOT WIDELY KNOWN.
AND THREE THE ALLOWANCE DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES WHILE IN A
FACILITY. OR ENTERED A FACILITY
WHEN THEY WERE AND HOUSE BUT
WANT TO FIND A NEW HOME AND
LEAVE THE FACILITY. I ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
MAKES THE HOME UPKEEP ALLOWANCE
A MORE EFFECTIVE SUPPORT OPTION.
BY DOING A FEW THINGS ONE IT
INCREASES THE AMOUNT TO THE
ACTUAL MINIMUM COST OF
MAINTAINING A HOME. INCLUDING
MORTGAGE RENT TO PROPERTY TAXES
UTILITIES AND REQUIRED INSURANCE
TOO IT ALLOWS PEOPLE AYE
INSTITUTIONALIZED FOR LONGER
THAN SIX MONTHS WHO LOST THEIR
HOMES OR NEVER HAD A HOME TO
BEGIN WITH TO ACCESS.
TRANSITIONAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE-
AND THREE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO PUBLICIZE THE H.
AWAY TO NURSING HOME RESIDENTS
PERSPECTIVE RESIDENTS DISCHARGE
PLANNERS AND MEDICAL OFFICES. I
JUST TO CLOSE THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS WE KNOW-
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE PROVIDES A PATH OUT
OF INSTITUTIONAL CARE- AND THE
ATTENDANT RISKS FOR DEATH. DEATH
AND ILLNESS FROM KOBE NINETEEN.
IN ADDITION ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
WILL FURTHER THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES CAN LIVE IN
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
SAFELY. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AN AYE VOTE SO THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
DEMONSTRATE OUR LEADERSHIP IN
CREATING A ROBUST HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES STEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXTER
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE-
AGAIN M. BAILEY AGAIN I AM A AND
THE LONG TERM CARE ADVOCATE THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. AS PART OF MY WORK
I PROVIDE COUNSELING TO SENIORS
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ABOUT MEDIC CAL IN
LONG TERM CARE OPTIONS. ON AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AIMS TO
PREVENT MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
WHO HAVE ENTERED A NURSING HOME
FOR SHORT TERM STAYS FROM LOSING
THEIR HOMES BY INCREASING THE
HOME UPKEEP ALLOWANCE FROM TWO
HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS TO THE
ACTUAL MINIMUM COST OF
MAINTAINING A HOME. AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING A TRANSITIONAL
NEEDS ALLOWANCE- CAN I RECEIVED
A CALL LAST WEEK FROM MISS TAN
THE DAUGHTER OF AN EIGHTY YEAR
OLD WOMAN WHO HAD RECENTLY
FALLEN AT HOME BROKEN HER LEG IN
AN- IN HOME FOR REHABILITATION.
THE DOCTOR TOLD MISS TAN THAT
HER MOTHER WOULD LIKELY RETURN
HOME IN ABOUT FIVE MONTHS HER
MOTHER LIVES IN AN AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING APARTMENT AND
PAYS ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH IN RENT. AS A NURSING
HOME RESIDENT A LONG TERM CARE
MEDIKAL SHE MUST PAY HER ENTIRE
MONTHLY INCOME AS A SHARE OF
COST KEEPING ONLY THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS AS A PERSONAL NEEDS
ALLOWANCE. ADDING IN THE CURRENT
HOME OF PEOPLE- AND SHE IS ONLY
LEFT WITH TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
DOLLARS TO PAY HER RENT AND
UTILITIES AND IS AT RISK OF. FOR
EVICTION AND THAT. BUT TEN A
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE WOULD
ENSURE HER MOTHER HAS A HOME TO
RETURN TO AND SHE IMPROVES.
INSTEAD OF FACING HOMELESSNESS
OR PERMANENT
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. INCREASING
THE HOME UPKEEP ALLOWANCE SO
THAT SHE CAN KEEP HER. INCOME TO
PAY RENT AND UTILITIES WILL
ALLOW MISS TOWNS MOTHER TO
TRANSITION HOME AND UTILIZE LESS
COSTLY SERVICES SUCH AS IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. OR PACE
PROGRAM INSTEAD OF REMAINING IN
IN AN EXPENSIVE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FOR THE REST OF HER
LIFE. CLEARLY AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE IS IT MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR BOTH THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA. AND FOR
THOSE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WHO
FACE LOSING THEIR HOMES WHEN
THEY ENTER A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FOR SHORT TERM STAY.
HERE I VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SHOWS A COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING SENIORS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES TO
RETURN HOME. AND DECREASE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL
HAVE A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND- YOUR NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE. LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON HERE OKAY YES
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YES MAIN PALETTE ON BEHALF
OF JUSTICE IN AGING AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- MADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE AT NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK THAT
WOULD HELP WITH CHOICE AN AGING
AND I'M IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. DO YOU LINE
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND ONE HUNDRED DO YOU HAVE A
SON MUTE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
IS SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AN AFTERNOON SHERRY BURNS BUT
THE AGENT SERVICES COLLABORATIVE
PERCENT OCCUR COUNTY AND THE
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
INTEGRATION COMMITTEE PERCENT OF
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THE LAST
ONE IN Q. IS NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND- DURING A ONE
ENGINE RESEARCH IS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE NONE. MISTER
LIVING WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANNA RECOGNIZE- THE
ADVOCATES AS WELL AS YOU AND
OTHER MEMBERS WHO OVER THE PAST
DECADE OF CONTINUE TO RAISE THIS
ISSUE- IT. IT WAS UNSETTLING TO
ME I LEARNED EVERY SINGLE TIME I
DO A BILL LIKE THIS I WAS
GRATEFUL THAT- THE COMMITTED
REACH OUT TO ME TO WORK ON THIS-
THAT PEOPLE ARE ESSENTIALLY.
SENTENCED TO LIFE IN THESE
FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY LOSE
THEIR HOME. WHICH OF COURSE IS
IT'S THERE'S A GRAVE INJUSTICE
THERE. IN THIS EXTRAORDINARILY
COSTLY TO EVERYONE ELSE. AND AND
WE CAN REVERSE THIS OP BY
CHARTING THIS COURSE ARE
SEXUALLY ASK FOR ABOUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR LEVINE DO WE
HAVE A WITH. A- MOTION. UP
MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MR MCCARTY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND- WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE OF MR LEVINE I'D LOVE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
SHOULD THIS BILL I'M- ABSOLUTELY
. A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
BIGELOW. REAL LARA MAIENSCHEIN
AS MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. IF YOU WE
HAVE FIVE VOTES THE WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL- WE WERE. YEAH
LIGHT ON MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SURE THANK YOU MEDICINE
AGAIN THANK YOUR STAFF AS WELL
THANK YOU. THIS BOERNER HORVATH. YOU HAVE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
TWO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
WOULD CLARIFY THAT LIFEGUARDS
WHO HAVE A LIFE GUARD
CERTIFICATION BY THE UNITED
STATES DEVON ASSOCIATION
CERTIFIED AGENCY MEET THE
TRAINING AND QUALIFICATION
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE SERVICES AT
PUBLIC SWIMMING POOLS AND
AQUATIC CENTERS DO THE STAFFING
SHORTAGES AS SORT OF COVERT
NINETEEN CITIES HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
LIFEGUARD THE LIFEGUARDS AT
POOLS RESULTING IN A REDUCTION
OF OURS AND WE'LL BUILD THE
AQUATIC PROGRAMS AND CLASSES.
THE CITY OF CALLED CARLSBAD THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL SOUGHT TO
USE OCEAN US NOT TO USE OCEAN
LIFEGUARDS TO KEEP CITY POLLS
OPEN HOWEVER THE CITY WAS UNABLE
TO DO SO BECAUSE OCEAN
LIFEGUARDS HAVE A DIFFERENT
CERTIFICATIONS AND PULL
LIFEGUARDS WALPOLE LIFEGUARDS
RECEIVE THEIR SORT OF FROM THE
CROSS FOR THE YMCA OCEAN
LIFEGUARDS ARE SIMILAR TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CERTIFICATION
RECEIVE THEIR CERTIFICATION FROM
AND WHO. UNITED AT SIXTEEN
SEVENTY WHAT ARE A LIE TO PER
LIFE OR SERVICES THREE POOLS IF
THE LIFE GUARD HAS TRAINING SORT
BY THIS AGENCY THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS NOT TO REPLACE RED CROSS
AND I AM CA TRADE LIFEGUARDS I
HAVE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL TO
EMPHASIZE THIS POINT AB SIXTY
THREE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE TO YOU
CARDS IN MY COURT ONLY WHEN
THERE'S A STARTER SHORTAGE OF
POOL LIFEGUARDS AB SIXTY TWENTY
TO SIXTY POOL QUANTICK CENTERS.
SO THEY CONTINUED PROVIDE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY HERE TODAY IS SAYING HOW.
AFTER THE BILL SPONSORED. BY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. AFTER ENSURE MEMBERS DANE
HUTCHINGS HERE ON HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
WHEN I THINK- ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BOERNER HORVATH AND HER TEAM FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO CARRY THIS
MEASURE FOR. AT THE CITY. LAST
YEAR THE CITY EXPERIENCED SEVERE
STAFFING SHORTAGES FOR PAUL
LIFEGUARDS DIP DESPITE THE
CITY'S EFFORTS AT ENHANCE
RECRUITMENT- WHICH INCLUDED A
MARKETING CAMPAIGN INCREASED PAY
RATES FOR BOTH PART TIME AND
SENIOR LIFEGUARD POSITIONS THE
CITY WAS FORCED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY. REDUCE POOL HOURS
BY AROUND SEVENTY PERCENT- DUE
TO INSUFFICIENT STAFFING LEVELS
. THE CENTERS PROVIDE INCREDIBLE
PUBLIC BENEFITS INCLUDING WATER
FITNESS YOUTH SPORTS AND
GENERALLY SPEAKING SERVE. AS A
PLACE OF COMMUNITY FOR OUR
CITY'S RESIDENTS. IN RESPONSE
THE CITY I'D- WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH IMAGE GRANTED EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATION TO PERMIT CITY
BEACH LIFEGUARDS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES SO LONG AS ADEQUATE
CROSSOVER TRAINING WAS PERFORMED
PRIOR TO THE SERVICE- ALL OF
CALLER CARLSBAD BEACH LIFEGUARDS
ARE MEMBERS OF KARL THAT'S FIRE.
AND AS A CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT
CERTIFIED BY THE UNITED STATES
LIFESAVING ASSOCIATION IS
TEMPORARY OPPOSITION EXPIRES AT
THE END OF JUNE OF ALL THE CITY
IS NOT NOT CONCERNED WITH
SEASONAL RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
OVER THE SUMMER AS IT STANDS WE
ANTICIPATE MORE SHUTDOWNS DURING
OFF PEAK MONTHS DUE TO LACK OF
STAFFING AND POOLS. AS A MEMBER
INDICATED EIGHT AB SIXTEEN SEVEN
TWO IS A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
WOULD PERMIT A PUBLIC AGENCIES
USE QUALIFIED BEACH LIFEGUARDS
TO STOP PUBLIC POOLS IN SUCH
EVENTS THAT WE CONTINUE TO FACE
STAFFING SHORTAGES WE HAVE
WORKED DLIGENTLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND LIFEGUARDS
COMMUNITY- AND THE AUTHOR HAS
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL APPROPRIATE CROSSOVER
TRAINING- WILL BE ADMINISTERED
PRIOR TO SERVICE. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CITY
COUNCIL MAKE A FINDING BY
RESOLUTION THAT A STAFFING
SHORTAGE- IS PRESENT IN ORDER TO
UTILIZE THESE PROVISIONS- THIS
IS TO SHOW UP INDICATE THAT WE
ARE NOT TRYING TO DISPLACE YMCA
OR RED CROSS LIFEGUARDS WELL IN
THESE TIMES OF NEED THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THIS
PROVINCE. ARE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR THIS
MEASURE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. CNN WILL GO AHEAD AND
PUBLIC GOT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
YOUR NAME. POSITION ON THE BILL
AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MADISON DOLLY WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN RED CROSS IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
TODAY BUT REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US- I THINK WE'VE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT- ALLEVIATE OUR
CONCERNS SO. LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THOSE IMPRINT AND THEN
ADJUSTING OUR POSITION
ACCORDINGLY SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. THE
NUMBER GO TO THE PHONE LINES
BOTTOM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONELINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. DIFFERENT
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MR MACE THOUGHT I
KNOW IT'S SHOCKING BUT I WAS A
LIFEGUARD FOR ABOUT FOR FIVE
YEARS- FACT- AND WATER SAFETY
INSTRUCTOR WAS ONE OF THE BEST
JOBS I'VE EVER HAD- STILL TO
THIS DAY I STILL WHEN I'M BACK
IN MY DISTRICT AND I'LL SHOW UP
TO SOME MEETING. I'M SOME NOW
PROBABLY SEVENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
WOMAN WILL COME OUT TO MEANS
THAT YOU TAUGHT ME HOW TO SWIM
WHEN I WAS IN MY- IN MY FIFTIES-
AND- I LOVE THE JOB SO I CAN
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THIS. FRANKLY
I'M GLAD AUTHORS BRING IN THIS
BUT THIS IS REALLY SORT OF SILLY
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
THE AMERICAN AMERICAN RED CROSS.
WHAT MA'AM IT'S NEED TO BE
TAKEN- THE BEACH LIFEGUARDS ARE
FAR SUPERIOR TO THE POOL
LIFEGUARDS LIKE LIKE ME. I WAS
LONG TO WANT TO BE ON A DAY
BEACH LIFEGUARD THEY GO THROUGH
A LOT MORE A LOT MORE TRAINING-
THEN THEN DO A POOL POOL
LIFEGUARDS IN THE FACT THAT THEY
DIDN'T MEET THE REQUIREMENTS YOU
HAVE TO FIX THIS. JUST SHOWS HOW
STUPID OUR LAWS OF OUR LAWS ARE-
SO I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
OF THIS MEASURE AND I'D LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS. THIS BILL AND WORK WITH
THE- THE AUTHORS THIS MOVES
THROUGH OF THE PROCESS. PEOPLE
TO SPEAK TO SOMEBODY THAT'S
GREAT BUT- GREAT BILL- TO BE
SUPPORTIVE THANK THANK YOU YES.
WE ARE TAKING A MOMENT TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THAT WILL MOVE
THEM ACROSS FROM. SUPPORT OF
AMENDED TO SUPPORT THEM. YEAH IT
WAS ABOUT DELETING THE REFERENCE
TO ACQUIRE INSTRUCTION AND
CLARIFY INTENTIONAL POOL
SPECIFIC CROSSOVER TRAINING IS
PROVIDED BY NATIONAL TRAINING
AGENCY THOSE THE TWO MEMBERS
THAT. THEY REQUESTED THAT WILL
BE TAKING THE NEXT COMMITTEE. AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE IS
. ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO SAY MISTER
BASS KIND OF SUMMED IT UP FOR A
SOFT. NOW IT NOW I LOST MY PLACE
I SHOULDN'T DO THAT RIGHT OKAY.
AS I'M VERY RUSTY OBVIOUSLY SO-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES. BIG
SURPRISE THERE- AND THE SECOND
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO- TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CARILLO LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I THIS
AREA. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. ONE SEVEN WE NEED
ONE MORE WE'RE SHORT A LIFEGUARD
SO WE'LL WAIT I MIGHT HAVE A
TOUGH FOR YOU. ALL OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR PATTERSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME FORWARD
YOU HAVE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
FOR US.
YOUR MOTION AND A SECOND EVERY
READY SIR. I MISSED. MISTER
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- TO PRESENT. IN TWO
THOUSAND FOR THE VOTERS ENACTED
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE WHICH
ESTABLISHED A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION WHICH
WAS TASKED TO OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. THE
COMMISSION IS MADE UP OF SIXTEEN
MEMBERS TWELVE OF WHICH ARE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS THE COMMISSION
LACKS REPRESENTATION IN THE
NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGIONS. THE BILL BEFORE
YOU WOULD URGE THE GOVERNOR WHEN
MAKING APPOINTMENTS TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
ENSURE THAT ALL TEN REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA AS DEFINED BY THE
TWENTY TWENTY SENSES. ARE
REPRESENTED EACH OF OUR
DISTRICTS TO HAVE VARIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND CONCERNS AND OF
THE BILL ATTEMPTS TO SEE TO IT
THAT THE COMMISSION DOES IN
ITSELF MINTS. REPOR THREE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIANS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. ARE
APPROPRIATELY REPRESENTED AND
ARE ABLE TO GET THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED SO THAT THEY CAN GET
ON THE PATH TO. RECOVERY IT HERE
IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
UP. A PAUL SIMONS WITH THE
DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT.
AND- A GARY ANDERSON WAS
SACRAMENTO YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. VENTURE WOODEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HI MY NAME'S PAUL
SIMMONS I'M WITH THE DEPRESSION
AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF
THE LEADING PEER DIRECTED
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOCUSING
PRIMARILY ON THE TWO MOST
PREVALENT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS DEPRESSION BIPOLAR
DISORDER. AFFECTING MORE THAN
TWENTY ONE MILLION AMERICANS-
DVSA ALSO WORKS WITH MANY OTHER-
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
PTSD ANXIETY DISORDER AND
NUMEROUS OTHER MENTAL CHALLENGES
AND DVSA CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE
GROUP I WORK WITH- IS THE
UMBRELLA ORGANIZATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS AND WAS.
ACTUALLY CO CREATED BY THE CO
AUTHOR OF PROP SIXTY THREE
RESCUE CLX- THIS BILL WOULD URGE
THE GOVERNOR AND IN MAKING
APPOINTMENTS TO CONSIDER
INSURING- GEOGRAPHICAL
REPRESENTATION AMONG THE TEN
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA. DEFINED
BY THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
CURRENTLY 75% OF THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE FROM THREE
DIFFERENT AREAS LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA. AND THE REMAINDER ARE
FROM OTHER COASTAL BASICALLY
COASTAL AREAS SAYS SAN DIEGO
SANTA BARBARA AND NAPA. A TO
ENSURE INCLUSIVENESS AND
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY IN
REPRESENT REPRESENTATION ON THE
COMMISSION GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY
IS ALSO CRUCIAL YOUR GRAPH
GEOGRAPHY'S NOT JUST A ZIP CODE.
IT'S A SOCIAL FABRIC SOME AREAS
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES THAN OTHERS
DIFFERENT NEEDS DIFFERENT
INFRASTRUCTURES. SO WHERE ARE
THOSE RURAL AREAS TO SMALLER
CITIES AND OTHER AREAS NOT
CURRENTLY REPRESENTATIVE. WHERE
HUMBOLDT. SO NOMA TEMECULA SAN
MARCOS FRESNO COALINGA MADERA
SANDWICHES ST STE STANISLAUS
COUNTY'S MIRAMAR PALM SPRINGS I
COULD KEEP GOING AND GOING-
ONTARIO POMONA. ANYWAY COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL I IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE MORE
EQUITY AND A SEAT AT THE TABLE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WOEFULLY UNDER
REPRESENTED AT THIS TIME IN MANY
WAYS IN THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KELLY ANDERSON AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH A
YOUTH RUN ORGANIZATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. OUR GROUP OF TEENS
WORKING TO HELP OUR PEERS BECOME
MORE COMFORTABLE TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS- AND
IMPROVING AWARENESS OF HOW TO
ACCESS SERVICES AND HOW TO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER. ONE THING WE
REALLY EMPHASIZE IS THAT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS IMPACT EVERYONE AND
WE ALL BENEFIT WHEN EVERYONE IS
MENTALLY HEALTHY AND RISK. I'M
ASKING TODAY FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. IT WOULD
REQUIRE APPOINTMENTS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
REPRESENT VARIOUS REGIONS OF THE
STATE. OUR WORK IS FOCUSED IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT- OUR GROUP
RECOGNIZES THAT YOUTH- STRUGGLE
TO ACCESS USEFUL INFORMATION AND
NEEDED SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE. IS CHALLENGES ARE OFTEN
MORE DIFFICULT AND RURAL AREAS
IN REGIONS WITH YOUR RESOURCES
AND FOR- DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATION HAS YOUTH FROM TWO
DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA- BUT WE'RE
CONSTANTLY THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN USE TECHNOLOGY ALTHOUGH
EVENTS OR- COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO ENGAGE TEENS
WHO ARE IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE DIRECTLY- CONNECTED TO.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE'RE
PLANNING A YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
EVENT THAT WOULD BE RESPONSIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF YOUTH ACROSS
THIS REGION- THAT EFFORT WAS
SUSPENDED BECAUSE OF CODED BUT
OUR GOAL STILL REMAINS TO MAKE
SURE. WE LOOK BEYOND THE SCHOOLS
WE ATTEND- FOR A MORE DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. WITH THAT IN MIND WE
ASK YOUR SUPPORT TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD AND THEIR NEEDS
RECOGNIZED THROUGH THE WORK OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CHANCE TO JOIN YOU TODAY I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEE NO ONE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION THE
CHAMBER. WE CALL THE CHAMBER. WE
CALL THE CHAMBER OKAY ALL RIGHT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. HELLO OKAY
I WILL WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF AMENDED
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT RURAL
CALIFORNIANS REPRESENTED THANK
YOU THANK YOU- WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINE SO- MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION IN. ORDER THAT ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN. ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND- ONE
MOMENT. AGAIN UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
NOBODY'S DOING UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. A QUICK COMMENT I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU KELLY I
BELIEVE- TESTIFYING TODAY. I'M I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING
THE VOICE OF YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW WE DO HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
. THE BILL HAS A- DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW A SECOND BY
MISS WALDRON I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER PATTERSON I
APPRECIATE UP. THE
RECOMMENDATION AND ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTIONS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD I WOULD I WALDRON WALDRON
HIGH AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE CARILLO LARA LARA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I THIS AREA.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. YOU HAVE A VOTE YOUR
BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OBVIATED VERY
MUCH. FIRST BILL OF THE DAY HERE
. MISTER SEYARTO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL. RECEIVE TO
YOU HAVE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YES. WELL
THANK YOU ON A WHEELCHAIR AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY THREE. FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
TO REFINE INFORM. THE AMENDMENTS
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT ESTABLISHES
THE CALIFORNIA FENNEL ABUSE TASK
FORCE. THIS TASK FORCE WILL
COLLECT AND ORGANIZE DATA ON THE
NATURE AND EXTENT OF FENNEL
ABUSE. AND EVALUATE APPROACHES
TO INCREASING PUBLIC AWARENESS
OF FENNEL THIS TASK FORCE'S
MEMBERSHIP IS DIVERSE INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE LEGAL
SYSTEM NONPROFITS AND HEALTH
AGENCIES. OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES CALIFORNIA AND THE REST
OF THE NATION HAS SEEN A RISE IN
OVERDOSES RELATED TO OPIOID USE.
DISTURBINGLY THE NEW FORM OF
OPIOID CALLED FENTANYL HAS TAKEN
THE EPIDEMIC TO NEW HEIGHTS.
THIS NEW WAVE OF DRUG DEATHS
AFFECTS CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
DEMOGRAPHICS AND COMMUNITIES
COST IN LIVES OF ALMOST FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ALONE. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE PHENYL
OVERDOSES BECAME RECOGNIZED AS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
AMERICANS AGED EIGHTEEN TO FORTY
FIVE MORE THAN SUICIDE.
HOMICIDES AND CAR. FEDERAL
DIFFERS FROM TRADITIONAL
PRESCRIPTION IN THAT ITS POTENCY
AND AVAILABILITY. ONLY TWO
MILLIGRAMS OF FENTANYL IS ENOUGH
TO CAUSE A SINGLE OVERDOSE. DATA
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT YIELDS THAT
IN THE BAY AREA ALONE OVER
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND GRAMS OF
FENTANYL WERE SEIZED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
ENOUGH TO FATALLY OVERDOSED PROX
ME FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE. ARE YOU ARE BRINGING
TOGETHER A STATEWIDE TASK FORCE
OF INDIVIDUALS ALREADY TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED. OUR HEALTH CARE
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORKERS ARE
TAKING THE BRUNT OF CARING FOR
OVERDOSE VICTIMS OUR HEALTH OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SPREAD EGG
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES OUR
SOURCES TO TRY AND BRING
AWARENESS. BUT ARE NOT AS
EFFECTIVE AS WE NEED THEM TO BE
. OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS HAD
THE DIFFICULT TASK OF AND
COMBATING THE ILLICIT PILLS AND
THEIR DISTRIBUTION NETWORKS THAT
CONTINUE TO RAVAGE OUR
COMMUNITIES. AN EPIDEMIC OF
THESE PROPORTIONS DESERVES A
RESPONSE THE BRINGS TOGETHER THE
BEST OF OUR STATE'S RESOURCES
EIGHT. SEVENTY THREE. PEOPLE
THAT THE DATA AND INDIVIDUALS TO
IDENTIFY THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO RESPOND TO THIS NEW FORM OF
SYNTHROID. OPIOID SYNTHETIC
OPIOID ABUSE. THOUGH MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE ITEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NO THEY
WITNESSED IT WAS GOING TO
TESTIFY WAS ABLE TO COME UP SHE
WAS GOING TO TESTIFY BY PHONE
OKAY THAT'S FINE THANK YOU I
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. C. NO
ONE OTHER WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND- PHYSICIAN IF
YOU HAVE ONE THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. THE NUMBER
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES- TO
OUR OPERATOR PLEASE. OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS STAR
FOLLOWED BY ONE. TO QUEUE UP.
ONE THOUSAND BY ZERO I'M SO
SORRY ONE FILED BY ZERO. BEGIN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. FOR AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AMATEUR NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OH
I'M SORRY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN RESOLUTION MUCH ROBBIE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS WALDRON- AND THEN MISS
RIGHT MISS RODRIGUEZ. I'M JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON OPIOID INFANT ALL
ISSUESSINCE MY DAYS IN THE CITY
COUNCIL WITH THE OPIOID TASK
FORCE BACK IN SAN DIEGO- I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
OF. THIS AMENDMENTS SOME FUTURE
TIME THANK YOU. LOOSELY THANK
YOU UP MR RODRIGUEZ. YES ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FORD OVERSEE. RESTORING
WHAT SHE WHAT DOES START
COMMUNITIES. BUT ALSO THE
DANGERS IT POSES TO FIRST
RESPONDERS OUT THERE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH OVERDOSES ON OUR
STREETS. ALSO WANT TO BE OUT OF
THE CO AUTHORS WERE FOR CAM. AS
OF THE GOVERNMENT PERHAPS A
LITTLE THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
BRING BACK TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION TO PUBLIC SAFETY-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE I
WOULD- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU IT SO WE
LOOKING FOR DID YOU MAKE IT
BATUM. CHIPPED PRESSURE TO MAKE
A MOTION- WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A MOTION. THIS WATER WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A MOTION. F. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ- WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
SECOND. ALL RIGHT I'M SORRY
MISTER MISTER MAYES YOU HAD YOU
HAD YOUR MOMENT OF GLORY EARLIER
SOUTH. YOU'RE TRYING TO
ENVISIONED NEVER MIND NEVERMIND-
SO AMEND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I CARILLO. LAURA
LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS
AREA. RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. NINE ZERO
YOUR BILL HAS NINE VOTES IS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH. SORRY MR WARD COME ON
UP SIR. THE WORD YOU HAVE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EVERY YEAR READY
. DO YOU HAVE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ARE FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL AND
ACCEPT THEIR AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN YOUR ANALYSIS. THANK
YOU I'LL BE BRIEF. WE KNOW WE'RE
FACING A CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
COUNSELORS. QUALIFY TREATMENT
COUNSELORS ARE OF VITAL
FRONTLINE RESOURCE FOR STATE AS
WE RESPOND TO THE GROWING OPIOID
CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. ARE
GRADUATE STUDENTS SEEKING A
CAREER MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FIELD PLACEMENT AS A SUBSTANCE
USE COUNSELORS AND EFFECTIVE
WAY. TO PRACTICE SKILLS LEARNED
IN THEIR COURSE WORK HOWEVER
UNLIKE MOST OTHER FIELD
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS. THE FACILITY
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL REGISTRATION
AND COURSE WORK AS WELL AS A
SMALL FEE. AB SIXTEEN EASES THE
REQUIREMENTS ON STUDENTS TO
STAFF- THESE TREATMENT CENTERS
BY ELIMINATING THE NEED FOR A
NINE HOUR CLASS IN THE FEES
REQUIRED. ON THE PHONE LINE WE
HAVE MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. TYLER INDEED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES. AND ADRIAN
SHELTON DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. BASE HERE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU. PREREQUI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS TYLER
RANDY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ABOUT ON
DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES- JUST
VERY BRIEFLY THIS MEASURE WELL-
ASSIST US IN OUR WORK FORCE
CRISIS WE REPRESENT SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROVIDERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK- HERE I FELT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
TERRY MEMBERS ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
REPRESENT NATIONALLY ACCREDITED
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WHO ARE SERVING YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN PUBLIC SYSTEMS. WE
ARE PROUD THIS BILL ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS- TO OUR WORKFORCE WE
ARE ALL IN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NONE OTHER OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE AUDITORIUM CHAMBER
WHAT WE WANT TO CALL IT. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE ANY
IPAD WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. YOU KNOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO I WANNA ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SUPPORTING.
ONE NINE ZERO ZERO. OKAY M.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE-
AGAIN LATER GEMMA IF YOU'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB ONE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY OR OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
CHAIR TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AT THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF. THE MEMBER WORK. C.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR SHARING OF THIS
BILL WILL BE ABLE TO HELP MORE
STUDENTS BE ABLE TO GAIN THE
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE THEY NEED
FASTER AND BE ABLE TO HELP MORE
INDIVIDUALS- STRUGGLING ON OUR
STREETS- EVEN QUICKER SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER MAYES SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED OUT OF SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
HAVE ARAMBULA BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE CARILLO LAURA LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. I KNOW
ZERO YOUR BILL HAS NINE VOTES IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON. THANK NUMBER
SUPPOSED TO WORK. I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE INDEX MAKE THEIR
WAY HERE THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
SO WE CAN- FINISH OUR BUSINESS
OVER IN TIME. WE DO HAVE A
CONSENT CALENDAR IT'S YOUR HERE
MOTION FOR THE CONSECUTIVE. SO
THE ANY ANYBODY. OKAY THE MOTION
FOR THE CONSECUTIVE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ MAKES A MOTION. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND SAID- MADAM
SECRETARY THE- CONSENT
COUNTERCOUP INCLUDES- ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINETEEN OH
SEVEN. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWO ONE FOUR FIVE AND I
REMEMBER ELEVEN A. B. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY TWO CEMENT SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ FROM. RODRIGUEZ SIZE
SANTIAGO. NINE ZERO THE BILL HAS
NINE AT THE BECAUSE SECOND HAS
NINE VOTES SO. GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON. THIS WEBER DR WEBER. YOU
HAVE AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MOVE THE BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD INCREASE THE
RATE AUGMENTATION FOR PHYSICIANS
WHO SERVE YOUTH WITH COMPLEX AND
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. AND EXPAND
TIMELY ACCESS TO VITAL SPECIALTY
CARE PHYSICIANS. PEDIATRIC SUB
SPECIALISTS HAVE GONE UNDER
EXTENSIVE MEDICAL TRAINING WHICH
OFTEN TAKES THREE TO SIX YEARS
BEYOND RESIDENTS SEEM. THE
STRONG STANDARDS OF CARE AND
PROVIDER CREDENTIALING CREATED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES PROGRAM CCS FOR SHORT
ENSURE THAT ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
OBTAIN CARE FROM EX FROM. FRANCE
PROVIDERS WITH APPROPRIATE
PATRICK'S CIVIC EXPERTISE.
CHILDREN THAT HAVE COMPLEX AND
CHRONIC HEALTH CARE NEEDS AND
CALIFORNIA ARE ENROLLED IN THE
CCS PROGRAM FOR THEIR SPECIALTY
HEALTH CARE. THESE CONDITIONS
PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALISTS TREAT
INCLUDE CONDITIONS SUCH AS
DIABETES THREE WILL CALL THE
EPILEPSY CONGENITAL HEART
DEFECTS CANCER CYSTIC FIBROSIS
AND PREMATURE BOTH TO NAME A FEW
. THE DEMAND FOR P. ADIC SUB
SPECIALTY CARE IS OUTWEIGHING
AVAILABLE PROVIDERS. THE RESULT
IS EXCEEDINGLY LONG WAIT TIMES
FOR APPOINTMENTS FOR MANY
SUBSPECIALTIES MEDICAL GROUPS
OFTEN HAVE MULTI YEAR DELAYS IN
RECRUITING NEW PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS. EACH YEAR MORE
MEDICAL STUDENTS ARE OPTING FOR
GENERAL TRACKS DUE TO POST
GRADUATE DEBT AND THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND COST IN LOST SALARY TO
BECOME A PEDIATRIC SUB
SPECIALIST. ADDITIONALLY WHEN
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIANS OPT TO
WORK IN OTHER STATES FOR THE
COST OF LIVING IS LOWER AND
DECAYED REIMBURSEMENT IS HIGHER.
IT IS OUR PATIENTS WHO SUFFER.
CCS PATIENTS FAMILIES ARE
TYPICALLY LOW INCOME IN FACT 90%
ARE ALSO ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
MEDICAID AL FOR THE PRIMARY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND ROUGHLY
70% OF CHILDREN IN CCS OUR
CHILDREN OF COLOR. AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT ADDRESSES THE
CHALLENGES BY INCREASING THE
RATE OF AUGMENTATION FOR CCS
PHYSICIAN SERVICES BY 25% RATE
HAS REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. AS COST FOR
DELIVERING MEDICAL CARE HAVE
SIMULTANEOUSLY SKYROCKETED. IN
ADDITION MY BILL ENSURES THAT
THE RATE INCREASE IS TARGETED TO
IMPROVING ACCESS FOR UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS BY REQUIRING THAT
ONLY CCS PHYSICIANS WHO ARE IN
PRACTICE IN AT LEAST 30% OF THE
PRACTICE PEDIATRIC POPULATIONS
ARE. BENEFICIARIES ARE THANK.
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT
ONLY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS BUT ALSO INCREASING
THE PRESENCE OF THESE PROVIDERS
IN UNDERSERVED AND RURAL AREAS
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO GENERATE A REPORT
EVERY THREE YEARS I WILL PUT THE
LOCATE OF THE UNLIKELY WRITINGS
SERVICE. LET MEANS CHILDREN
HOSPITALS ARE LEFT IN LARGE
CITIES. THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CHILDREN NOW
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND MANY OTHERS.
HERE TO SPEAK WITH ME TODAY IS
DR CARLOS LEARNER A CCS PANEL
PHYSICIAN WHO PRACTICES AT UCLA
AND ALSO SERVES AS THE PRESIDENT
ELECT OF THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION.ENHANCING AND
APPARENT KID WHOSE DAUGHTER IS A
CCS PATIENTS WITH MULTIPLE
SUBSPECIALTY MEANS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I TERM
WOULDN'T MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M DR CARLESS LEARNER
AS MENTIONED I'M A GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN AND PROFESSOR VICE
CHAIR OF PEDIATRICS AT THE DAVID
GEFFEN SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AT
UCLA. I'M ALSO MEDICAL DIRECTOR
OF THE PEDIATRIC MEDICAL HOME
WHICH PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE
PRIMARY CARE FOR CHILDREN
COMPLEXITY. I HAVE THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS PRESIDENT ELECT OF
THE CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY
CHEMICAL. WHICH IS ON PROP
ADVOCACY. SENATE SPECIAL GROUP
CLOSE NINE WE CAN LICENSE
TERTIARY SAW IN THE STATE. OUR
MISSION IS TO AND THAT CHILDREN
WITH HEALTH COMPANY HAVE. I TO A
COULD OF HEALTH. I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCING UP AND DOWN
THE STATE WITH REGARD TO
GUARDING ACCESS TO SPEECH. CARE
HE IS THE LEAD. YEAH CALIFORNIA
AND FIFTEEN AT ACROSS THE STATE
FOR MY FRAGILE CHILDREN. YET
IT'S RATES HAVE REMAINED
STAGNANT FOR TWENTY YEARS THIS
CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING HAS SLOWLY
ERODED THE ABILITY OF MEDICAL
GROUPS TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY ACCESS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YES YOU CAN A-
SPECIAL DOCTOR SURVEY. FOR MANY
OF THE PEDIATRIC SPECIALTIES WE
FOUND A MEDICAL GROUP. THE
REPORT SAID THAT THE TIME FOR
NOT. PRINCESS I THANK MY- OF OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THEY WAIT
MANY WEEKS FOR NEEDED SPECIALTY
CARE SOMETIMES LEADING TO
UNNECESSARY EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS HOSPITALIZATIONS IN THE
SAME SURVEY FOURTEEN OF THE
SIXTEEN SPECIALTY REPORTED LOTS
OF TIME OF YEAR AND SOMETIMES
WERE TWO YEARS. COULD ADDRESS
LIST ONE MEDIC GROUP IN-
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN TRYING FOR
SEVEN YEARS TO RECRUIT THREE PT
OUT THE CRIMINOLOGIST. SUCH
THESE COME LONG TRIPLE TIME FOR
FAMILIES SEEKING CARE OR EVEN
FORGOING CARE WE FEAR THAT
DISTRICT FUNDING GAP IS NOT
ADDRESSED THE SACK TO SIT WILL
REACH CRISIS WILL SOON. PLEASE
RAY PIPER STABLE SAILING YEP YEP
SPECIALTY NETWORK BRINGING COMP
TO MEDICARE LEVELS UNLIKE A PAY
WHO CAN BILL MEDICARE FOR A
PORTION OF THEIR PATIENTS- THE
PAEDIATRIC NETWORK DEPEND
HEAVILY NCCS FOR SUPPORT THE
RATE OF INFLATION WILL HELP
RETAIN MORE SPECIALS IN
CALIFORNIA RATHER THAN LOSING
THEM TO OTHER STATES LEAD MORE
MEDICAL STUDENTS TO CHOOSE
PATRICK SPECIALTIES PRIEST THE
MEDICAL GROUPS OF THREE TO
ATTRACT MORE PHYSICIANS TO
SHORTAGE AREA. AND EXPAND OUR
SAID SATELLITE OFFICES OR RURAL
REGIONS WHERE ACCESS TO CARE IS
MORE CHALLENGING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
GIVE NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR WOULD AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS NANCY NEDERLAND AND I AM
THE MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN
LIVING WITH COMPLEX HEALTH
CONDITIONS MOST OF THE FOUNDER
OF KIDS IN CARE GIVERS A
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES WELLNESS
AND NAVIGATION RESOURCES FOR
FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS OF
CHILDREN LIVING WITH CHRONIC AND
COMPLEX ILLNESSES I ALSO SERVE
ON THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAID
CHILDREN'S HEALTH ADVISORY PANEL
AND THE FAMILY ADVISORY COUNCIL
FOR UCF BENIOFF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS PORT FOR
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU HOW THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY WILL BENEFIT FAMILIES
LIKE MINE. WE BUILD OUR FAMILY
VIA FOSTER CARE BY ADOPTING A
SIBLING GROUP LIVING WITH
MEDICAL COMPLEXITIES. BEFORE
MEETING MY YOUNGEST DAUGHTER IN
THE NICK YOU I MET WITH THE
PEDIATRIC CARDIOLOGISTS TO BE
HER ECHO CARDIOGRAM SEPTEMBER
ALL SHASTA WHERE SHE WAS BORN TO
OAKLAND CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. SHE
WAS BORN AT THIRTY TWO WEEKS
WITH AN ARRAY OF HEALTH PROBLEMS
TODAY MILIA MY YOUNGEST IS
FOURTEEN SHE LOVES HORSES ANIME
AND RAMAN. AND LIVES WITH WHERE
A RARE COMPLEX SYSTEMIC AUTO
INFLAMMATORY DISEASE AS WELL AS
I. B. D. PRODUCT MIGRAINE ASTHMA
SHUTS DISEASE EIGHTY D. AND
LEARNING DISABILITIES. EMILY'S
CARE TEAM NOW INCLUDES OVER
TWENTY THREE MEDICAL
SUBSPECIALISTS AT TWO DIFFERENT
MEDICAL CENTERS IT'S TAKEN YEARS
TO BUILD HER TEAM AND IT'S STILL
NOT ALWAYS EASY TO ACCESS HER
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER NOR TO
COORDINATE ALL THE MOVING PARTS.
IF WE'RE LUCKY REFERRAL
AUTHORIZATION APPOINTMENTS ARE
SCHEDULED IN WEEKS THOUGH THERE
HAVE BEEN TIMES IT IS LITERALLY
TAKEN OVER A YEAR TO SECURE AN
APPOINTMENT FOR NEEDED REFERRAL.
MANAGING MY DAUGHTER'S CARES
TAKEN HOURS OUT OF EACH WORK
WEEK AND HE'S MIGHT IMAGINE HAS
TAKEN A TOLL ON MY CAREER. I
KIDS SCHOOLING OUR FAMILY
FINANCES WE NOW SCHEDULE
VACATIONS AROUND SPECIALTY CARE
APPOINTMENTS AND BIRTHDAY
PARTIES AROUND OUTPATIENT
INFUSION MEET SET UP
APPOINTMENTS. GETTING
AUTHORIZATIONS AND APPOINTMENTS.
IN A TIMELY MANNER HILLS LIKE
WINNING THE COMPLEX CARE LOTTERY
. DURING COVERED WE RELOCATED TO
NAB NEVADA COUNTY ON A PART TIME
BASIS OUR FAMILY LOVES TO HIKE
RIDE HORSES AND ENJOYS THE
SLOWER PACE OF THE MOUNTAIN
TOWN. PART TIME BECAUSE THE
SPECIALTY CARE MILLION NEEDS
DOES NOT EXIST NEAR OR IN. THIS
WORLD COUNTY WE REGULARLY DRIVE
TWO AND A HALF TO THREE HOURS TO
UCSF AND SPENT PART OF EACH
MONTH IN THE BAY AREA IN ORDER
FOR EMILY TO GET THE CARE THAT
SHE NEEDS. JUST LAST WEEK
FOLLOWING A HOSPITALIZATION
EMILY IS PEDIATRIC
RHEUMATOLOGIST TOLD ME TO
SCHEDULE A FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENT
FOR FOUR WEEKS OUT. WHEN I
CALLED TO DO SO I WAS TOLD THE
NEXT AVAILABLE APPOINTMENT WAS
MID JULY. FOUR MONTHS NOT FOUR
WEEKS AWAY. ATTY AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT CANNON WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY
CARE. THE CHILDREN LIKE A
MILLION DEPEND ON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NONE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE CHAMBER OF WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. WHAT'S YOUR NAME
POSITION AT AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE IF YOU REPRESENT ONE
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WOULD TEN
MADDEN REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AT ONE BAR BONTA BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KATIE ANDREW
THE CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. A
MUCH NO ONE ELSE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND HAVE THE
OPERATOR OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR- TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
FOR- AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. CINDY
HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO I TESTIFY ON THIS BILL
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. FIVE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALISON RAINY ON
BEHALF OF THE PEDIATRICS MEDICAL
GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MR SURE THERE'S NO
OTHER PURCHASE WAS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THIS IS YOUR CURRY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR FOCUSING THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE IN OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AS WELL WITHOUT I'D LIKE TO-
COOPER YOUR BILL WHEN IT
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE THIS WALDRON. I REQUEST TO
JUMP ON AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL-
AS CO CHAIR OF THE RARE DISEASE
CAUCUS WE RECOGNIZE HOW. EARLY
DIAGNOSIS IS REALLY WRITTEN. A
LOT OF TIMES A MOM WILL HAVE
THAT SENSE THAT SOMETHING'S NOT
RIGHT. AND SHE HAS TO KEEP
FIGHTING FIGHTING FIGHTING
FIGHTING AND YOU KNOW HAVING.
MORE PHYSICIANS IN THE CRITICAL
SUBSPECIALTIES WILL MAKE THAT
FIGHT A LOT EASIER. HOPEFULLY
AND- HELP WITH NO LONGER TIME
GOES BY AS WE KNOW. THE MORE-
IMPACTED PATIENT OUTCOMES ARE.
ESPECIALLY IN YOUNG PEOPLE IF WE
COULD YOU KNOW GET THAT
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT EARLIER
WHOSE COULD REALLY HELP YOU KNOW
THEIR LIFE AS THEY GO FORWARD
SO- I DO. DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CUT. WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND FOR THE
LIFE OF ME I DON'T KNOW WHO DID
IT AND SO. IT WAS OVER THERE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE A ROW
THERE MISS AGUIAR-CURRY IS A
MOTION AND A SECOND BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. OF THE MOTION WOULD BE
DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS BUT-
DOCTOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HEARING OUR BILL TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE WITNESSES WHO ARE
HERE AND THOSE THAT CALLED- BY
INCREASING OUR CCS AUGMENTATION
RATE. ABOVE CURRENT LEVELS
CALIFORNIA GROUPS. WILL BE IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN PHYSICIANS. I HEAR IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY CARE FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. LARA OR I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. AND GET TEN VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON. THANKS
DOCTOR WEBER. THIS AT THIS POINT
MR RODRIGUEZ IS GOING TO PRESENT
FOR MR RAMOS WHO IS UNABLE TO BE
HERE AT THE MOMENT SO. RAMOS IS
GOING TO PRESENT AB. TWENTY ONE
FORTY FOUR. WE GET AT ARSENAL GO
BACK WITH A TICKET ABOUT MOTION
ON. ITEM NUMBER TWO- A. B.
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK WELL I WAS
AT THE HARMONY WAS AMAZING AS IT
IT WASN'T YOU IT WASN'T YEAR SO
THAT WILL GIVE IT TO MR MCCARTY
AND MR THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR
THE MOTION ON THAT. THAT WAS A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO. JUDY WELL
IT THAT'S THIS ONE- IT IS IT IS
YOU JUST NEVER MIND OKAY SO I
WAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DIGEST SO WE WILL GO S. AS WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE VOTE
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM MISTER-
RODRIGUEZ SO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WATER NOT
VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CARILLO LARA LARA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA. RIVAS
RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO. SO BELIEVE THAT
BILL A CALL WITH HAS SEVEN VOTES
SO. OKAY ARE MR RODRIGUEZ PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU NEW FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST THIS
COMMITTEE HELD AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE LATTER RENT
FUTURE SHORT LPS ACT IN DECEMBER
AND THEN FOR. A RELIABLE DATA ON
THE LPS INVOLUNTARY HOLDS AS
EXCERPTED NEVER AGAIN EVER OF
CONCERN AB TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR
DRESSES THIS CONCERN AND WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SECURELY TRANSFER
INFORMATION RECEIVED FROM
DESIGNATEDFACILITIES ON THE LPS
HOLDS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
REQUIRED DH CS TO ACT. ON THIS
DATA MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
REQUIRE A COMMUNITY HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE CURRENTLY
THE LACK OF DATA HINDERS POLICY
MAKERS IN THE EFFORTS TO MAKE
INFORMED POLICY DECISIONS AND TO
ADDRESS DISPARITIES IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY FOUR WERE SATISFIED ONE OF
THE TOP RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
RESEARCH AUDIT OF THE OUT CYST.
AND IT DOES. REMAIN THIS ABOUT
THEY WORK EFFECTIVE AND HUMANE
POLICY AND PRACTICES FOR TREE
ARE MENTALLY ILL AB TWENTY ONE
FOUR DATA SHARING ENSURE
DESIGNATED HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
PROVIDE UP TO DATE DATA ON LPS
HOLDS TWO ENTITIES WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF SH OVERSEEING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SUPPORTED
IMPROVEMENTS INTO THE SYSTEM AND
THAT MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH CARE
TO THOSE CRISIS CAN BE BETTER
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE TODAY
YOU WILL HEAR FROM A LOCAL ART
OF DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FROM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU CHAIR
WOULD AN HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A OKAY I DON'T WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION FIRST I
DID WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS REFLECT FLAVORED
REFLECTING SIGNIFICANT EXPERTISE
IN THE AREA OF THE OLD VETERAN
PETRA SHORT ACT AGAIN KNOWN AS
THE LPS ACT I ALSO WANTED TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR CONVENING
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN
DECEMBER ON THE LPS ACT THIS
HEARING BROUGHT TO LIGHT MANY
ISSUES OF CONCERN INCLUDING THE
LACK OF RELIABLE DATA ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TREATED
INVOLUNTARILY UNDER THE LPS
FACT. THIS SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
IS WHAT AB TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR
SEEKS TO IMPROVE BY
STRENGTHENING THE STATEWIDE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING ON
INDIVIDUALS HELD ON SHORT TERM
INVOLUNTARY SEVENTY TWO HOUR
PSYCHIATRIC HOLDS COMMONLY KNOWN
AS FIFTY ONE FIFTIES AB TWO
TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR WOULD
IMPLEMENT AND EXPAND UPON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR IN HER
JULY TWENTY AUDIT OF THE LPS ACT
BY RICK BY REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR DOJ.
TRANSMITTED DATA THAT THEY
RECEIVE ARE FROM LPS DESIGNATED
ENTITIES FOR THOSE HELD ON FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES FOR BEING A DANGER
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS THE DATA
WOULD BE REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE D. EIGHT CS AS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS TREATMENT THESE ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT CERTAIN SHORT
TERM HOLD INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER INDIVIDUALS
OUR PRE HIT. FOR HIM FROM FIVE
ARMS. BECAUSE OF CONFIDENTIAL.
THE LAW. IS NOT SHARED INCLUDING
WITH ENTITIES THE COULD PROVIDE
SUBSEQUENT SERVICES OR ENTITIES
THAT CAN EVALUATE THIS DATA TO
IDENTIFY HEALTH DISPARITIES.
TODAY THE SOLE HOLDER OF THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE DATA ABOUT
SHORT TERM HOLD IS IT AGENCY
WITHOUT DIRECT RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OVERSEEING OUR PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OUTLET AS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO
COLLECTING THE DATA IS USING THE
DATA TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE TO GET CS TO REPORT
ANNUALLY. AGGREGATED DE
IDENTIFIED FIFTY ONE FIFTY
INFORMATION STRATIFIED BY COUNTY
ETHNICITY GENDER AND MEDICARE
ENROLLMENT STATUS. THE EIGHT CSU
IS THEN REQUIRED TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO READ
REDUCE DISPARITIES IN MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT ACROSS THE
STATE. THE GOLAN THE INTENT OF
TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR A LINE
WITH THE BROADER DATA COLLECTION
GOALS OUTLINED AND OTHER LPS
REPORTING BILLS INCLUDING THE
ONE CO AUTHORED BY OUR CHAIR- AB
. I NEED TWENTY TO SEVENTY FIVE
OUR BILL AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
FOUR STATES A DH CS CAN TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION ANY EXISTING
OR NEW LAWS AND ENSURE THAT
REPORTING FACILITIES ARE ONLY
REQUIRED TO REPORT. LPS
INFORMATION ON ON INVOLUNTARY
HOLDS ONCE NO DUPLICATIVE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE
FACILITIES FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE ON TWENTY
ONE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEEING NONE WE WILL ASK
FOR- THE AUDIENCE IN THE CHAMBER
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
THE KNOWN WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. WERE OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MEMBERS CARE
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE BILL DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MR RODRIGUEZ- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. THE
MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY- THIS WALDRON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES RESPECT PRIVATE AND
ALSO INVITE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
JOIN IN A SCHOOL AUTHORS IF YOU
LIKE. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL MAN OF
MADAM SECRETARY. WOULD I WOULD I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. LARA OR I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO. ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES IT'S OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON. THANK YOU. YOU YOU
YES WOULD YOU ANYBODY VIæT UP
PLEASE CALL. WILL BE TAKEN IN
THE NEXT- YEAH. OKAY SO WE WILL
THAT THAT IS ALL OF THE BILLS
FOR THE HEARING AT THIS POINT SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
TOP OF THE ORDER HERE AND- HAVE
ADULTS POLICE- WE HAVE MEMBERS
MISSING MISTER SUN I WILL CALL
YOU OUT BUT I WILL- I JUST DID-
BUT THE WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS
MISSING- AND WE WILL ONCE WE GO
AFTER WE FINISHED GOING THROUGH
THIS WE WILL LEAVE WE WILL BE
HERE FOR FIVE MINUTES AND IF
THEY'RE NOT HERE THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT VOTING
SO OKAY. SO- PLACEMENT SECTION
THE START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER ONE FIVE
SEVEN AND EIGHT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY AND- SO- HELLO IT'S A
COUNTER PLEASE. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. REAL MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE SANTIAGO. I'M
SORRY NAZARIAN. THE CHECKOUT-
NAZARIAN II. WELL THAT HAS
TWELVE VOTES WILL GO AHEAD MOVE
ON NOW ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
EIGHTEEN OH NINE MISTER YOUR
CURRY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WHOOPS THAT
WAS THAT WAS NOT THAT WAS AT
LEAST LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AREA NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I SANTIAGO. EIGHT TWO
ZERO THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES
IT'S OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON. I DON'T
NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN HUNDRED
BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AREA. LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA THIS AREA
AND I REQUEST RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I. ELEVEN
TWO ZERO THAT HAS ELEVEN VOTE SO
THAT BILLS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS ADD ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE A DOCTOR ARAMBULA PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WALDRON. WALDRON I.
CORREO LAURA. LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. THIS AREA THIS AREA AND I
RIVAS RIVAS AYE SANTIAGO. AS
TENNIS- THAT'S TEN ZERO LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX- AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
UP BOERNER HORVATH PLEASE. LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I CARILLO
LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON ITEM NUMBER NINE DA BY MR
LEVINE PLEASED WITH THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WALDRON
WALDRON AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BIGELOW. A REAL. LAURA LAURA
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I THIS
AREA. TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RIVAS HI
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ZERO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS ITEM NUMBER
TEN MISTER PATTERSON AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I. CORREO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I THIS
AREA. NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVAS I
SANTIAGO. AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT MISTER PATTERSON. SANTIAGO
I. THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU OF
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS SAT ON
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE BY MISTER
RAMOS PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AREA. THIS
AREA. NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY MR SAY ARTS- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
CORREO. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE THIS AREA. THERE AND I
UNDERGO SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN VICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
CARILLO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I THIS AREA. NAZARIAN EYEING
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THIRTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU THEN FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN BY DOCTOR WEBER
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MARIA. SANTIAGO.
I'M SORRY IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ZERO
ZERO SO OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF. I THINK WE'VE GOT EVERYTHING
EXCEPT FOR ONE MEMBER OF. OH
SORRY GOT TO GO BACK. ALRIGHT WE
MISS SOMETHING WITH MR CENTER
WILL GO BACK TO THE CONCERT.
CONSENT CALENDAR YEAH. AT IN A
SECOND HERE. YOU YEAH WE GOT
CHECK. SO BECAUSE SECOND- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AREA. SANTIAGO MONTERO
ARE THIRTEEN AND ITEM NUMBER TWO
I AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CORREO SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. NINE ZERO ZERO. I THINK WE
GOT A ITEM NUMBER- FOUR I'D
NEVER FOR AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE A DOCTOR REGULAR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. OF THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CARILLO. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. ELEVEN ZERO ZERO. I
THINK WE GOT I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
THANK YOU. SO WE WILL WAIT FOR A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREE WHO IS
CHAIRING A- BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
. WE WAIT FOR A FEW MINUTES SO
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE WILL GO AHEAD NOW WILL
GO TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA WE
HAVE. FIVE ITEMS ON CONSENT SO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR INCLUDES
SECULAR CURRY AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN. OUR QUE HAN AB
NINETEEN OH SEVEN THAT'S
CALDERON AB TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN
MISS DAVIES AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
FIVE MISTER PATTERSON AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AREA.
NUMBER TWO A. B. EIGHTEEN OH
NINE BY MISTAKE YOUR CURRY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AREA. I KNOW I.
ITEM NUMBER THREE- AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AREA I. WELL
THAT'S TWELVE. TWELVE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FOR A DOUBLE CHECK. YEAH
AB NINETEEN NINETY FIVE A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS A REAL
HIGH REAL HIGH TWELVE TWELVE
TWELVE ZERO ITEM NUMBER SIX A BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
I DIDN'T EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CORREO
I RIO HIGH. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE BY
MR LEVINE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW
CORREO I MEAN THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT IS OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AREA HI HI
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE BY SEVEN MEMBER
RAMOS AB TWENTY ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CARILLO HI MARIA
I FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE BY MISTER SEYARTO
PLEASE THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MARIA. HI MARIA I
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MARIA HI MARIA I
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN BY A DOCTOR AFTER
WEBER EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MARIA HI
MARIA I THINK. ZERO CONCLUDES
OUR AGENDA SO. COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.